...
Wo ist die Musik raus?
Wo ist die Musik rausgegangen?
Die hängt einfach!
Was ist da los? Oh, die Emotes sind ein bisschen groß.
Mein Sound ist kaputt, ich weiß.
Moment mal, das muss man kurz mal fixen.
Weil Teams gerne am Sound rumste...
Nee, ist gar nicht kaputt.
Nice.
I've hadder.
Jo.
Ich gestern den ganzen Tag daheim rumgebaut.
Sowohl an der Technik als auch an der Existpoint Positionierung.
Das war echt...
Ich hasse Technik manchmal einfach nur.
Obwohl ich mein ganzes Leben halber Lebensinhalt Technik ist.
Beziehungsweise mich halt berufstechnisch drum kümmere.
Aber es ist echt der Wahnsinn, wenn die Scheiße nicht funktioniert, wie sie funktionieren soll.
Mein Raspberry Pi im Wohnzimmer kackt immer ab.
Ich bin jetzt dahinter gekommen, woran das liegt.
Wahrscheinlich, weil...
Die SSD zu viel Strom verbraucht.
Ja...
Naja, was willst du machen? Der Kram muss halt funktionieren.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die SSD zu viel Strom verbraucht.
In Kombination mit dem TV-Tuner.
Ich bin mir auch nicht mal so sicher, ob das so eine gute Idee ist, dass ich im Wohnzimmer einen Raspberry Pi mit einem USB-Tuner...
...für Fernseh gucken. Also ich gucke ja kein Fernseher. Ich bin ja leider nicht der Einzige hier.
Was das angeht...
Es gibt da Leute, die gucken gerne Fernseh.
Ich verstehe es nicht, aber okay. Ich meine, soll jeder machen, was er will.
Also im wörtlichen Sinne...
Vielleicht...
Obwohl das ein ganz anderes Thema ist.
Wobei das den ganzen Tag über funktioniert.
Also ich hätte ganz schön Probleme, wenn das nur morgens klappen würde.
Weiß nicht.
Wäre ungesund.
Meine Mutter ist 72.
Die guckt Fernseh.
Also du hast prinzipiell recht.
Aber wobei, gibt bestimmt genug.
Die ist 72.
Die guckt jeden Tag Fernsehen. Die guckt auch so komisches Zeug wie Tatort und sowas.
Und...
Das Problem ist halt...
Das ist alles...
Das ist alles Müll.
Fernsehtechnik ist einfach Müll.
Du kannst...
Über... Okay.
Du könntest über den Fernseh gucken.
Dann bräuchtest du, dass du alles gucken kannst.
So eine komische Smartcard...
Von Vodafone.
Wo sie dir verdienen...
Wo sie dir verbieten können...
Das Fernsehprogramm...
Aufzunehmen...
Zu spulen...
Oder Timeshift zu machen.
Das ist Gängelung von Vodafone.
Das ist Gängelung für das, was ich bezahlen soll.
Also ich bezahle und werde dafür gegängelt.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Das ist so weirdchamp, dass Leute es überhaupt machen.
Bleibt halt zur Auswahl frei empfangbare Programme.
Aber aufnehmen auf dem Fernseh kann ich nicht gescheit, weil das Vendor-Login ist.
Und du kannst es nirgends woanders dranhängen.
Sollte mal...
Ich den Fernseh wechseln oder so.
Bescheuert. Also im Endeffekt bleibt mir nur übrig.
Aufnahme zu machen über
Raspberry Pi mit USB-Tuner.
Keine privaten Programme in HD zu gucken.
Und...
Nur so kann ich halt alles machen, was ich machen will.
Aber das geht mir auf den Keks.
Weil...
Das irgendwie sehr unstable ist.
Das gibt bestimmt... Was weiß ich...
Einmal...
In der Woche vielleicht irgendwie den Geist drauf.
Und ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt.
Ich vermute am Stromverbrauch
von Raspberry Pi. Also richtig
painschamp.
Hat jemand von euch mal sowas hier ausprobiert?
Ähm...
Hat jemand mal
solche Kisten ausprobiert?
Habt ihr mal sowas ausprobiert?
Also ich will die nicht haben.
Ähm... Weil ich
damit auf den Fernseh gucken will.
Sondern weil die Tuner wohl ganz gut sind.
Du hast einen UNO 4K, okay.
Ähm...
Das ist gut, dass du einen hast.
Da muss ich dich gleich mal was fragen.
Welches Image hast du dafür?
Und... Ähm...
Also ich hab mir das so gedacht, man könnte das
Ding als Tuner verwenden und als Aufnahmebox.
Und gucken würde ich weiterhin mit
Kodi auf dem Shield-TV.
VTE-Image, okay.
Hast du...
Holst du den EPG?
Holst du den EPG aus dem...
Achso, was hast du? DVB-C, DVB-S, also Satellit.
Und holst du den EPG
übers Internet oder holst du den EPG
aus dem Stream vom Anbieter?
Moin. Äh, danke für den Sub übrigens.
Irgendwas hab ich hier vergessen, Freund.
Stubenhocker. POG.
Also quasi PO-G.
Ich bin dieser Aussprache
so weggeblieben.
PO-G.
POG.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist richtig.
Das Problem ist nicht, in dem Fall
nicht das Raspberry Pi Netzteil,
sondern, dass die USB
SSD...
Ähm...
Zu viel Strom braucht
mehr als die USB-Ports liefern können.
Ich hab's jetzt schon probiert mit einem USB-Hub,
aber das ist auch Müll.
Es riecht wie ein riesiges Kabelgedöns und funktioniert auch nicht richtig.
DVB-C Vodafone, nice.
Okay, das wäre das gleiche Setup bei mir.
Funktioniert das mit dem EPG?
Hast du, äh,
Genre und
Titel und Serientitel und sowas drin?
Weil da hatte ich bei TV-Headend
richtig Probleme,
dass das Genre aus dem EPG
funktioniert bei mir bis heute nicht richtig mit TV-Headend.
Ich meine nicht, dass das Genre jetzt
irgendwie großartig wichtig wäre,
aber Fernsehsendungen, ich meine, du guckst eher nach dem Titel,
aber es wäre schon nice,
weil daraufhin kann Cody nämlich
den EPG entsprechend einfärben.
Also, also,
ja,
das würde mich echt interessieren,
ob du alle Daten aus dem,
aus dem EPG bekommst, die man,
die man haben will, so.
Naja, also wie gesagt,
ich weiß nicht, ob sich das lohnt, ich würde damit
nicht Fernsehen gucken, ich würde es nur als Aufnahmebox
und Streamingbox verwenden,
aber wahrscheinlich funktioniert es besser
als ein Raspberry Pi mit USB-Tuner.
Theoretisch hätte man die Option,
wenn man eine Vodafone-Smartcard hat,
da auch mit so halblegalen Mitteln
private Programme in HD zu entschlüsseln
und dann ohne Restriktionen, aber da
habe ich gar keinen Bock drauf.
Ah ja, mal gucken.
Können wir uns theoretisch
im Stream angucken?
Ja.
Nee, dann ist wahrscheinlich, dann ist wahrscheinlich.
Ja, also normalerweise wird DVBC
über das DVB-Signal
normalerweise ausgestrahlt, ob eine Sendung, keine Ahnung,
ein Spielfilm ist, eine Serie ist,
Drama ist, Comedy ist oder so was.
Und wenn er
erst der EPG erfasst,
dann
kann Cody
das EPG entsprechend einfärben.
Ist aber jetzt nicht so wild.
Guckst du auch direkt darüber Fernsehen
vom Tapes oder streamst du das
dann von da auf eine andere Box?
Ich bleib auf jeden Fall bei meinem Shield-TV,
Android-TV als Frontend einfach wegen den ganzen
Apps drauf, weil nur so kannst du
von Netflix bis Prime Video
bis YouTube und so alles gucken.
Das geht ja über das Teil sonst gar nicht richtig.
Ja, der
EPG funktioniert bei mir auch,
nur macht der EPG öfters mal Probleme.
Manchmal fehlen Senderkomponenten.
Das hat TV-Headern, hatte bei mir schon immer
Probleme mit dem EPG.
Das kann aber auch an meinem USB-Tuner liegen.
Es ist durchaus möglich.
Manchmal gehen
manche Sender nicht für ein paar Tage.
Die sind dann einfach leer.
Warum auch immer, dann erholt sich das Ganze wieder.
Wie gesagt, das Genre cremen
funktioniert teilweise nicht.
Es ist merkwürdig, aber ich meine es ist
brauchbar. Es ist in Ordnung.
Kann man benutzen.
Viel mehr Probleme habe ich,
dass der Raspberry Pi abkackt und es dann nicht funktioniert.
Und ich hasse es, wenn Technik
nicht funktioniert, in dem Sinn, wenn ich
dann um Support gefragt werde.
Und wenn die drüben sitzen,
oder drüben sitzt,
im Wohnzimmer und
das nicht geht und ich dann genervt
werde mit, guck mal der Fernseher geht nicht,
das fuckt mich ab. Ich will irgendwas,
was einmal aufgesetzt
wird, dann deaktiviere ich Updates und dann
funktioniert es einfach.
Scheiß auf Updates. Wenn es dazu führt,
dass es kaputt geht, ist mir doch wurscht. Das Ding soll einfach
nur Fernseher anzeigen, gut ist.
Shield TV hat Updates aus.
Android Apps haben Updates aus.
Kodi Plugins
haben Updates aus.
Alles Updates aus. Das ist ein Setup,
was funktioniert. Ich mache da keine automatischen
Updates, kriege eine neue Kodi Version und der Kram
funktioniert nicht mehr. Ganz bestimmt
nicht. Das mache ich höchstens, wenn es Probleme gibt,
update ich mal alles.
Moin Wolle, danke für den Sub.
Huge Subscription, ich brauche neue Kekse, die sind fast
die meisten Leute, die lang dabei sind, haben schon
alle den Gold Keks mit Kette.
Gibt es nicht schon so einen
Intel NUC mit Kabelanschluss?
Nö.
Es gibt diese Dinger, wie gesagt, es gibt diese
Dinger an Boxen, die haben dann auch
ein Octo-Tuner oder so drin.
Da kannst du irgendwie acht Sachen
gleichzeitig empfangen, das sollte, glaube ich,
für so ziemlich alles im Haushalt reichen.
Ich will mich demnächst für ein duales
Studium Wirtschaftsinformatik bei einer
Bank in der Nähe von Frankfurt beim
alles schwer ist es, da so an Platz ranzukommen.
Ganz ehrlich, aktuell ist es
also ok, ich habe keine Erfahrung,
was duales Studium angeht.
Also es kann sein, dass ich jetzt komplett
falsch liege, aber allgemein ist es relativ
easy aktuell in der IT irgendwelche Jobs
zu bekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es als dualer Student
aussieht, aber für die Azubis
ist es gerade gut, für ausgelernte
Leute, studierte Leute, eh.
Generell Jobs in der IT sind zur Zeit easy.
Was aber
witzig ist, das ist so die Branche, die geht
da auch komplett gegen den Trend, überall
anders werden Stellen abgebaut,
weil die ersetzt werden durch
AI, Roboter,
Automatisierung, Optimierung,
Outsourcing, was auch immer.
Und in der IT brauchst du dann immer mehr
Leute, aber das gleicht trotzdem nicht aus.
Auf Dauer denke ich mal.
Was ich aber witzig finde, Leute, eine
Sache,
ich glaube eine Sache, die
man spät, die man die
letzten Jahre über schon gelernt hat und spätestens
jetzt, seit dieser
Krise da in Russland oder mit Russland
und allem, ich glaube, dass die ganze
Outsourcing-Geschichte ein bisschen
zurückgefahren wird.
Weil man hat jetzt gesehen, dass es
ziemlich doof ist, sich von Russen oder China-Chinesen
abhängig zu machen.
Gerade bei den Chinesen, die einfach mal
keine Schiffe nach Shanghai reingelassen haben.
Tja.
Ich glaube, das wird auch
Auswirkungen darauf haben, dass die Leute sagen
okay, wir lassen es mal mit Outsourcing ein bisschen bleiben.
Mal gucken.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Meine Stonks sind immer noch im Keller,
aber das macht nichts.
Es ist eh nur ein World ETF.
Das geht auch wieder hoch.
Ich könnte jetzt eigentlich noch mal ein bisschen was kaufen.
Gut.
Was der Raspberry Pi von einem Freund auch zicken gemacht,
weil er an einem...
Jaja, wie gesagt, das ist nicht das Problem.
Die SSD verbraucht zu viel Strom.
Das merke ich auch daran,
wenn ich...
Normalerweise ist das kein Ding. Der Raspberry Pi
taktet sich runter, wenn er
zu wenig Strom hat. Aber ich sehe es ja auch im Log.
Die SSD krackt ab.
Und ich kann das auch nachstellen.
Wenn ich die SSD an USB 2
anschließe, ist überhaupt kein Problem, aber
sobald ich sie an USB 3 anschließe
und die auch ein bisschen Strom zieht, weil sie ordentlich
Übertragungsrate hat,
krackt die mir ab.
Ich mache entweder eine andere SSD dran
oder ich schmeiße den Raspberry Pi
komplett weg und kaufe mir vielleicht doch
irgendwie sowas als Streaming Box bzw.
rein als Fernsehbox.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Das ist jetzt schon ein Problem.
Alter.
Space Musik
Ich versuche gerade mit WebSocket
eine Webseite asynchron vom Server
abzudehnen. Ist aber...
WebSocket ist das Einzige, was
du nehmen kannst, sinnvoll.
Es gibt noch verschiedene Rapper. Du kannst Signal
A nehmen oder sowas. Das ist im Prinzip auch
nur ein Rapper, um sowas in der Richtung
um Legacy-Browser zu unterstützen, bleibt ja nix anderes übrig außer WebSockets zu
nehmen.
Mittlerweile, wobei das stimmt nicht so ganz, mittlerweile kann man auch gRPC über
HTTP machen und du kannst CraftQL-Subscriptions verwenden, aber CraftQL-Subscriptions sind
im Endeffekt auch WebSockets, also eigentlich gibt's nur WebSockets.
Du kannst natürlich auch die Easy-Variante, die tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht ist,
du kannst auch einfach periodisch abfragen, du kannst auch einfach alle 15 Sekunden abfragen.
Je nachdem, wieviel Daten da sind, dann mag das gar nicht so schlecht sein, ja.
Okay, dann würd ich mal über einen neuen Provider nachdenken.
Also, ich mein, ich bin mit Vodafone jetzt ja auch nicht so super glücklich, ja, aber
da hätt ich echt, würd ich mir gedacht machen, wenn ich drei Internet f- also ich hatte ja
früher genau für diesen Fall auch zwei Internetverbindungen, ich hatte ja noch Backup, Telekom-Leitung
und Vodafone, aber man muss sagen, das hat sich gelohnt, ich hab den Kram hier abgestellt,
es war einfach unsinnig Geld, ich hab's eh kaum verwendet und die Vodafone-Geschichte
ist so weit ganz, ganz okay, relativ, relativ in Ordnung, ja.
Ich überleg grad, ob ich auch Vodafone-Business-Upgrade hab die auch am Freitag oder Donnerstag irgendwann
mal angeschrieben auf Twitter und da meinen sie, ja, wir beantworten dir alle Fragen,
da hab ich ihnen die Fragen geschickt und hab gesagt, nein, Business-Fragen beantworten
wir nicht.
Also, ja, okay.
Dann wollt ich den Business-Account auf Twitter anschreiben und die wollen nicht auf Twitter,
die muss man anrufen.
Da sieht man halt, das ist Boomer-Boomer-Business-Zeug, weiß ich grad, ob ich da Bock drauf hab.
Ich mein, warum soll ich mit echten Menschen kommunizieren und reden am Telefon, wenn
ich das auch schreiben könnte über Twitter?
Versteh ich nicht, ja, könnte man machen.
Dazu brauch ich erstmal ne Fritzbox-Cable, ich hab keine Fritzbox-Cable und ne Fritzbox,
was kosten die aktuell?
Cable Fritzbox, Fritzboxes mit Cable, da, so, braucht das alles nett.
Was ist das für ne komische Benahmung, Alter?
Ich brauch kein Wi-Fi da drinnen, ich brauch nix, ich brauch einfach nur Tuner, haben die
alle Tuner?
Wo sieht man denn, was die für Tuner haben?
Steht gerade dabei, oder?
Oder haben die alle?
Ok, gucken wir mal, Amazon.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob ich Unity Worlder von Business mach, boah, ist aber auch nicht
grade billig.
Wobei, es geht, gibt für andere Sachen mehr Unsinnig-Geld auch.
Das ist ein Vierer, der Vierer zieht eh schon mehr Strom, aber das kommt auf die SSD an,
also das ist bekannt, wenn man im Internet danach sucht, der Raspberry Pi hat Probleme,
oder was heißt Probleme, weiß gar nicht, ob es am Raspberry Pi liegt, der hat Limitierungen,
was Stromverbrauch über den USB angeht, und wenn du ne SSD hast, die in Spitzenzeiten quasi
mehr verbraucht, dann kackts ab.
Naja, alle Millisekunden nicht, aber alle Millisekunden ist mit Websocket vielleicht
auch etwas Hardcore, also ganz ehrlich, weißt du, was ich machen würde, wenn ich alle Millisekunden
was zum Updaten hätte, ich würde weder Websockets nehmen, noch sonst was, ich würde irgendeinen
konstanten Stream nehmen vom Server zum Client aus, irgendeinen Streaming-Kram, der einfach
nicht aufhört.
Du brauchst ja hier gar nichts Asynchrones, man kann ja bei einer Millisekunde nicht wirklich
von Asynchron benachrichtigen sprechen, wenn das eh alle Millisekunde kommt, dann würde
ich einfach irgendeinen Stream aufmachen, der permanent liest.
Hattest du meine Kabel, ich habe immer noch einen Kabelanschluss.
Moin, Schwulius Caesar, KappaPride, ja doch, ich habe immer noch einen Kabelanschluss,
habe ich ja.
Übrigens Leute, ich habe die 5Headed Star Heimautomatisierungsidee gesehen seit langer
Zeit gestern in einem Forum und zwar, der Typ hat, alter was macht denn Darkreader, der
Typ hat sich einen Regensensor gebaut und zwar jetzt halt euch fest, mit einem Wasserleak
Sensor, aber anders als man eigentlich so denkt, also die Dinger sehen so aus, das ist
Zigbee, das ist dieses Xiaomi Akara Zeug, die Dinger sehen so aus und die haben unten
zwei Kontakte und die Idee von diesen Sensoren ist, die legst du hier hin auf diese Kontakte
und wenn es unten drunter nass wird, dann leitet es zwischen den beiden Kontakten und
das Ding meldet, dass irgendwo Wasser ausläuft, aber der hier ist auf die clevere Idee gekommen,
sich ein Regensensorbord zu nehmen und das anzulöten unten dran, also die Kontakte werden
nicht verwendet, um hier quasi per Kurzschluss zu erkennen, ob der Untergrund nass ist, sondern
die werden quasi als Sensoreingang verwendet für diesen Regensensorbord, für dieses Regensensorbord,
also das ist wirklich massiv pfeifert, auf die Idee wäre ich gar nicht gekommen, wobei
das theoretisch mit jedem x-beliebigen Sensor funktioniert, wo du halt Binary Sensor Sachen
anschließen kannst, aber das fand ich sehr pfeifertig, die Sache ist nur die, ich werde
es nicht bauen, weil diese Regensensorbords richtig beschissen sind, die rosten und ging
kaputt nach 2-3 Jahren draußen, also eigentlich komplett sinnlos, aber die Idee fand ich massiv
pfeifertig.
Ich habe mir auch schon überlegt, Leute kennt ihr mal irgendeine gute Wetterstation, SeaWave,
Zigbee, WLAN oder meinetwegen auch 433 Megahertz Funk, die man gescheit in Home Assistant
einbinden kann, weil, was mir jetzt schon öfters aufgefallen ist, dass die ganzen Outdoor-Temperatursensoren
nicht so hundertprozentig genau sind und dass es relativ praktisch ist, wenn man weiß, ob
es geregnet hat in letzter Zeit, ob es gerade regnet, man sieht ja auch kleine Regen nicht
unbedingt immer, wie Sonnen-Einfall am Tag war, wie der Wind so ist, da weiß man beispielsweise
schon gleich morgens, was man anziehen muss, ich meine, Alternativ ist, man könnte einfach
mal kurz im Unterhemd vor die Tür gehen und dann gucken, was man anzieht, aber, ich meine,
warum sollte ich im Unterhemd vor die Tür gehen, wenn ich auch eine WLAN-Wetterstation
bei mir an die Wand hängen kann, logisch, oder?
Sag mal, Chat, sagt gerade keiner was, oder ist der Chat kaputt?
Muss ich gerade mal testen, Keg-Waid, ne, ich glaube, es sagt bloß einfach keiner was,
nice.
Chat, Chat, nicht, nicht Vorkge, Chat, Wettege, Hab, diese direkt in HA Integrate funktioniert
mega, Waldbeck, Halley Profi-Wetterstation, 6 in 1 Messung auf einen Blick, das ist doch
ein China-Chinesen-Ding, oder?
Der Name von diesem Ding ist schon wieder, ja, das ist garantiert Waldbeck, das ist doch,
es klingt nicht China-Chinesen, aber es ist bestimmt China-Chinesen-Zeug, die haben es
deutsch benannt, weil die denken, das ist, das muss ich mir jetzt mal gucken, ob das
wirklich China-Chinesen-Zeug ist oder nicht, ja, es ist China-Chinesen-Zeug, ja, sonst
hätten die eine deutsche Webseite, Waldbeck, irgendeiner in China ist auf einen deutschen
Markennamen-Generator gekommen und da ist dann Waldbeck rausgekommen, das soll quasi
nach deutschem Hersteller klingen, ist es aber nicht, es ist wahrscheinlich China-Chinesen-Gramm,
sieht man auch an diesen AliExpress-Bildern schon, die sind schlau, oder?
Also eins, was wir den Chinesen lassen, in der Richtung sind die wirklich Business-Stonkstechnisch
ganz vorne mit dabei.
ECOVID, das kenne ich nicht, ECOVID, das ist aber bestimmt irgendwas mit Cloud, das will
ich nicht.
So, das Ding hast du integriert, okay, lässt sich das, wie lässt sich das integrieren?
Wie integriert man das in Home Assistant, kann das Ding direkt MQTT, das glaube ich kaum,
was braucht man dafür?
By the way, die Fernbedienung sieht fast eins zu eins so aus, wie die Fernbedienung für
meine Klimaanlage, naja gut, außer diesen Löcher hier, das Ding sieht schon ein bisschen
Hardcore billig aus, ja, Moment, ist das einfach eine stinknormale 433 Mhz-Punkanlage und man
braucht einfach einen Empfänger dafür?
Such mal ECOVID Hacks, was ist das?
Wetterstation, ECOVID Weather Station Integration for Home Assistant, okay, ah, das ist cool
und die geht damit, ja die Dark Sky API, die habe ich auch und das geht damit oder wie?
Das wäre natürlich äußerst Pipeheader, das, oh Mann, Leute, da muss jetzt irgendwie
einer ankommen wieder, nein nein, China produziert heißt nicht automatisch schlecht, deutsche
Produkte werden auch in China produziert, das ist richtig, deutsche Produkte werden
in China produziert, aber die haben nicht zu, wie soll ich sagen, die haben nicht zu
unrecht diesen Ruf weg, dass das Standard China-Chinesen Produkt vielleicht jetzt qualitativ
etwas zu wünschen übrig lässt, das ist immer noch so, die produzieren gute Sachen, beispielsweise
Staubsaugerroboter, aber man sieht den Unterschied auch bei Staubsaugerrobotern, wenn man mal
so einen Xiaomi Staubsaugerroboter aufmacht oder irgendeinen aus den USA oder Deutschland
entworfen, dann muss er nicht mal in Deutschland produziert sein, da siehst du gleich den
Unterschied, was für uns gut ist, weil die meisten China-Chinesen-Geräte total easy
zu modden sind, die legen beispielsweise keinen Wert drauf, dass das ordentlich implementiert
ist, was Wi-Fi-Security oder sonst was angeht, du kannst Dinge teilweise aus China OTA flashen,
die nicht OTA geflasht werden sollen, du hast Rootkeys im Internet, wo du dich auf
jedem Gerät einloggen kannst und sowas in der Richtung, bei uns ist das gut, die modden
wollen, insgesamt spricht es aber schon dafür, dass man dort, naja, gerade was Bildquality
und Security angeht, oftmals nicht so der Sache den Stellenwert beimisst, den man sich
wünschen würde.
Und die meisten Sachen, die du auf AliExpress billig kriegst, sind nicht umsonst billig,
das muss man sich ja auch mal sehen, das muss man sich ja auch mal vor Augen halten, der
Kram ist ja nicht umsonst billig.
DVB-T-Stick, also ich habe einen Empfänger für 433MHz, das sollte noch eigentlich reichen,
oder?
Also das heißt, du kannst, nur dass ich das immer richtig verstehe, du kannst dieses
Ding hier nehmen, dann per USB anschließen an dein Home Automation Rechner und das dann
einrichten in Home Assistant mit dieser Integration, oder wie?
Das ist ja mal 5 header hochzählen, das finde ich geil, das mache ich glaube ich, das wird
geordert dann, wenn das so geht, über WLAN, über WLAN, wie jetzt, warum brauche ich diesen
Empfänger dann noch, wenn ich WLAN mache, was, das verstehe ich nicht, ist das hier
nicht USB angeschlossen, weil die ist doch nicht WLAN, oder, WLAN fähig, das müsste
du mir nochmal, funktioniert nicht im WLAN, ach Moment, die Station wird mit Batterien
versorgt, ne, kann ich die nicht anschließen an irgendein Kabel, ich will die nicht mit
Batterien versorgen, kann man die nicht, das hält doch nicht, das hält doch dann wieder
ein halbes Jahr, wenn man die versorgt mit Batterien, ne das ist doof, also mir wäre
das mit einem ordentlichen Kabel schon lieber, genau an der Ecke wo ich das positionieren
würde, habe ich nämlich auch ein Stromkabel, was sehr POGG ist, naja, aber ich brauche
kein, also wie gesagt, ich muss das sowas nicht über, ach so, ok, das ist natürlich
auch cool, ok, also dass ich das richtig verstehe, was man machen muss ist, man hängt die Wetterstation
draußen irgendwo hin, macht Batterien rein, dann nimmt man diese Basisstation hier, und
dann, wo schließt man, diese Basisstation, das hier ist nur ein Stromkabel oder was,
und die Basisstation hänge ich dann ins WLAN, also die Basisstation kommt ins WLAN, und
das kann ich dann mit der Integration Home Assistant einrichten, warum kann man nicht
direkt das RF Signal abgreifen und braucht dieses Zwischending hier nicht, das finde
ich aber gut, das überlege ich mir tatsächlich, ne, die Anzeige brauche ich nicht, die kommt
bei mir dann aufs Tablet, und wie genau ist das, kann man auch so, ja ich habe einen 433
MHz Empfänger dran für meine Rollladen, ist das überhaupt die EcoVid Schatze, anscheinend
nicht, aber anscheinend kompatibel dazu, sagt zumindest der Chat, Internet Connected, ja
wahrscheinlich nur mit der Cloud, das probiere ich aus, sehr guter Tipp, wenn der Chat sagt,
dass es funktioniert, dann probiere ich das, der Chat ist ja prinzipiell eigentlich immer
richtig, der ideale Begleiter für alle Wetterfrische, oh nein Leute, ich wurde geflamed von Jörg
Kachelmann auf Twitter Leute, wo ich das gerade lese, ich benutze die falsche Wetterseite,
hat er mir gesagt, ich soll kachelmannwetter.de verwenden, ich habe mich beschwert auf Twitter,
dass die Wettervorhersage in letzter Zeit so schlecht ist, ähm, ich habe geschrieben,
warum ist die Wettervorhersage in letzter Zeit so schlecht, haben die Hardware downgraded,
gestern hieß es noch 10 Stunden Sonne, und irgendwann antwortet, alter Twitter, geh mal
nicht auf den Sack man, ich will da einfach nur her, nooo, Gott, nooo, Gott, please no,
no, no, nooooooo, guck, ich wurde von Jörg Kachelmann persönlich geflamed, dass ich
nicht die richtige Wetterseite verwende, ich soll gefälligst kachelmannwetter.com verwenden,
ja, tja, dann muss ich das wohl machen, die deutsche Wetterdienst App, die habe ich auch
auf dem Handy, das ist die App, die sie nicht mehr kostenlos anbieten durften, weil sie
zu gut war, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt Leute, das ist richtig hängen geblieben,
der deutsche Wetterdienst hatte mal eine Wetter App, die nannte sich Warnwetter, das ist dafür
da gewesen, ursprünglich mal um, doch, das ist sein Ernst, Überschwemmungen, Unwetter
und so zu warnen, die haben die dann aber mit der Zeit ausgebaut, dass du im Prinzip
die beste Wetter App, die es gab, hattest, du hattest alles drin, zig verschiedene Screens,
Wind, Regen, Wolken, auf welcher Höhe, sonst wie, das war die beste Wetter App, die es
gab und die war halt, weil sie quasi, wie soll man sagen, eh schon steuerfinanziert
ist irgendwie, war die kostenlos, das heißt diese Warnwetter App vom deutschen Wetterdienst
war die beste Wetter App kostenlos und irgendwann hat wetter.com geklagt dagegen, dass das
irgendwie wettbewerbsbeeinträchtigend wäre, wenn die beste Wetter App kostenlos angeboten
wird, weil was sollen sie denn da machen, und daraufhin hat ein Gericht entschieden,
dass diese App nicht mehr kostenlos angeboten werden darf, nur noch die Basisversion, um
Wetterwarnung rauszusenden, also das muss man sich mal überlegen, die beste Wetter
App war kostenlos und irgendein Gericht hat gesagt, die darf nicht mehr kostenlos sein,
das ist doch nicht vermittelbar an die Leute, oder, das heißt, der deutsche Wetterdienst
macht die gleichen Sachen wie vorher von meinen Steuern, was okay ist und sie hätten
es kostenlos angeboten, jetzt kriegen sie halt nochmal extra Geld, ganz ehrlich, ich
kauf mir die auch, die deutsche Wetterdienst App, ist kein Problem, kostet irgendwie 230
oder so, weiß ich gar nicht, ob die noch, DVD Warnwetter, genau, das ist die kostenlose
glaube ich, so, das ist die kostenlose, die hat jetzt nur noch Basic Funktion und die
neue, die, oder vielleicht hat sie auch mittlerweile intern was zum kaufen, zumindest die Standard-Version
ist jetzt nur noch, also die Standard-Kostenpflichtige Version ist jetzt nur noch eingeschränkt,
es ist total hängen geblieben, das muss man sich echt mal vorstellen, die bieten kostenlos
eine bessere Wetter App an, als die, die bezahlt wird, so, easy Wettbewerb, geht nicht, muss
auch was kosten, naja, okay Leute, was können wir uns denn heute mal anschauen, zeig mal
ja, Interview mit einem Agil-Coach, oh nee, das fand ich letztes Mal schon nicht lustig,
wir sind viel zu agil, um uns coachen zu lassen in Agilness, wir leben agil, wir sind agil,
da brauchen wir keine Coaches für, der Chat ist eh der agilste Chat auf der Welt, wir
machen nicht Daily Stand-Up, wir machen minütliches Stand-Up hier, wir stehen quasi nur noch,
ganz ehrlich, da kommt bestimmt auch noch demnächst irgendwie einer der Manager-Leute
drauf, Daily Stand-Up ist zu wenig, wir brauchen jetzt stündliches, das darf nicht Stand-Up
heißen, das braucht dann irgendwie, irgendwie was anderes, stündlicher Austausch oder
sowas, stündliches Update-Stand-Up oder sowas, nee, das gibt's immerbei, das gibt's wahrscheinlich
schon, das ist dann, sonst ist man nicht agil genug, wie geht's der Katz, tja, weiß ich
nicht, wo die gerade rum eiert, wahrscheinlich irgendwo, ich hab hier die Tür zu, vielleicht
legt sie irgendwo rum, der 34234 Fernseh-Typ hat ein neues Video, ja, das hab ich schon
aufgemacht, irgendwas mit 3D-Drucker, so, was verdient ein Rohrleitungsbauer, da ein bisschen
sieht der Typ aus wie, wie Superman, oder, so, so, ganz, so leicht auf den ersten Blick,
oder, oder wie Geralt, oder, was hat er denn sonst noch gespielt, ehrlich gesagt, da sind
zwei Sachen ein, was hat er denn sonst noch gemacht, der hat bestimmt total vielen Filmen
gespielt, äh, bei Mission Impossible war er, glaub ich, auch mit am Start irgendwann, ähm,
keine Ahnung, ich weiß, wie heißt denn der, der Actor überhaupt, Henry Cavill, glaub
ich, ja, was hat er denn sonst noch gemacht, mir fällt eigentlich nur ein Witcher und Superman,
und, wie gesagt, ich glaub, bei irgendeinem Mission Impossible Teil 75, oder so, war er
auch dabei, ach, keine Ahnung, interessiert mich auch nicht, wie würdest du eigentlich
einen Raspberry Pi mit SSD betreiben, äh, mit Festplatte schon mal gar nicht, mit SSD,
äh, USB auf SATA, oder eine USB-SSD, wobei, wahrscheinlich kostengünstiger, USB auf SATA
ist, und nehm ne SSD, die nicht so viel Strom verbraucht, du musst aufs Klo, exellent, EA
wird immer schlimmer, ist das so, das wollen wir uns nachher mal angucken, ok, Leute, wir
lassen uns LevelCapture baiten, oh, ne, wenn ich den Titel schon lese, Battlefield 22
New Map Teaser Data meint, jawoll, Leute, 6 Monate, 7 Monate nach Release, es kommt
eine neue Map, endlich, wir haben alle drauf gewartet, alle, Moment, alle, übrig gebliebenen
3676 Leute, 3414 Leute haben darauf gewartet, ich nicht, ich nicht, ich bin da durch, wenn
da jetzt für dieses Game nicht noch irgendwas riesiges kommt, wovon ich nicht ausgehe, bin
ich da mit durch, ok, zeig mal her, ich finde übrigens Data Miner so gut, das hört sich
immer so an, als, ähm, lassen die da, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Grafikkarten, äh, 2
Wochen irgendwelche Battlefield Teile, Files analysieren und haben das dann Data mined,
oder so, es ist ja Blödsinn, du guckst dir, also die einfachste Form vom Data Minen ist,
keine Ahnung, du machst irgendwelche Files mit dem Hex-Editor auf oder lässt dir Strings
extrahieren aus Dateien, das geht ja relativ einfach, ähm, und guckst, was drin steht,
natürlich gibt es zwar bestimmt auch die ein oder andere komplizierteren Techniken,
aber es hört sich so, so super, wie soll ich sagen, so, so super sophisticated abgedreht,
hoch, äh, wissenschaftlich an, die meisten Leute machen tatsächlich sowas Binwalk oder
Strings oder im Zweifelsfall einfach nur einen Hex-Editor auf und drüber scrollen, so, zeig
mal her, ja, es ist übrigens, eins haben wir gelernt Leute, habt ihr den Modern Warfare
Teaser gesehen, es ist nicht Teaser, genau, kann man das nicht ins Vollscreen machen auf
dem PC oder was, was ist denn das, Alter, dieser Zoomer-Scheiß-Mann, was ist das denn,
wer hat sich das überlegt, also ich kann den Kram auf dem Smartphone ohne Probleme
in Fullscreen machen, ich mein halt, halt wenn ich, äh, auf dem Desktop hat er so Balken,
das ist mir klar, aber mit Balken ist es trotzdem größer als hier, Shorts durch Watch, wirklich,
zwei Fett, alter, einer Chat, wieder, exzellent, so, pass mal auf, es ist nicht Modern Warfare
2, es ist Modern 2 Warfare, nicht Modern Warfare 2, wir haben uns getäuscht, es ist Modern
Warfare. Okay, ich gebe zu. Cringe, Cringe-Joke. Ja, okay, ist gut. Weiter.
Wisst ihr, was ich geil finde bei Level Cap? Der macht zwar jede Woche irgendwie noch in
irgendeiner Art und Weise Battlefield in seinen News, aber Bock, das Game zu spielen,
hat er auch nicht mehr, weil das ist immer nur Trailer-Footage. Und das Geile ist, im
Trailer sieht das ja auch noch ganz brauchbar aus. Der Trailer hat uns alle so verarscht.
Das ist wirklich grenzwertig. Es ist ja normal, dass Trailer quasi die Sachen,
die da sind, besonders geschönt darstellen. Aber die haben in dem Trailer Dinger gezeigt,
die gar nicht vorhanden sind in dem Spiel. Und, sag mal, das, was vorhanden ist,
ist maximal missverständlich dargestellt. Das ist ein Panzer mit einem Schneeschieber.
Was soll denn das geben, wenn es fertig ist? AI-Soldiers. Ja gut, AI-Soldiers. Brauchst
die ja auch, weil keiner mehr das Spiel spielt. Super, ein Tank mit einem Schneeschieber. Perfekt.
Dass da noch keiner drauf gekommen ist, Leute. Da brauchen die bis 2042, bis die so was erfinden.
Aber eigentlich ist doch ein Schneeschieber an einem Panzer total bescheuert, oder? Jetzt mal
ernsthaft. Du willst ja mit einem Panzer nicht zwangsläufig die Straße frei machen. Du willst
mit dem Panzer vorwärts kommen. Dementsprechend brauchst du ja auch keinen Schneeschieber am
Panzer. Also das ergibt doch wenig Sinn. Egal. Moment, ist mein Lautstärk stimmig. Lautstärk ist ok, oder?
Ok, im Juni, im Juni. By the way, könnt ihr euch gerade erinnern, wie cool das im Trailer
aussah und wie lame das in-game aussieht? Oh, Falling Rocks? Das gab's ja noch nie.
Falling Rocks, also jetzt. Ne. Next-Gen. Wahrlich nicht. Next-Gen. By the way, mit Modern Warfare 2,
oder mit Modern 2 Warfare, ist die Storyline eh komplett im Arsch. Bisher konnte man noch sagen,
hey, Modern Warfare 1 von 2019 war ja quasi so die Vorgeschichte zu Modern Warfare. Das sieht man
auch im Outro, wo er irgendwas von Soap und Task Force 141 und so was erzählt. Natürlich hat damals
schon nicht alles gepasst und sie haben dann gesagt, ja, das ist nur inspiriert und wäre ja ein
anderes Universum und bla bla bla bla bla. Aber spätestens jetzt, damit ist es eh komplett vorbei.
Das ergibt eigentlich nichts mehr zusammen genommen Sinn. Ich dachte, es wäre wahnsinnig schlimm für das Game, aber trotzdem. Ich finde es immer noch
bescheuert, dass das ein Ding ist überhaupt. Es war klar, dass es kommt, weil es hat sich
saumäßig gut verkauft 2019. Sicherlich auch aus dem Nostalgie-Faktor, weil viele Leute gesagt haben,
oh ja, Modern Warfare war damals geil, jetzt kommt es neu. Das wird sich wieder gut verkaufen,
hundertprozentig. Ich finde es aber absolutes Armutszeugnis, das habe ich auch schon mal im Video
gesagt, dass es überhaupt quasi ein Reboot gibt von Modern Warfare, von einem Game. Ja, Modern Warfare
ist ein Game, also das ist nicht so alt, es ist nicht so, dass es technisch jetzt wahnsinnig schlecht
wird oder so. Dass es jetzt quasi ein Game rebooted wird, was keine Ahnung, zehn Jahre alt ist oder so und
maßgeblich die Serie zu dem gemacht hat, was es heute ist. Also warum, warum, warum rebooten? Ich
verstehe dieses ganze Reboot an allen Ecken nicht. Aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht schon, aber aus kreativer
Sicht ist es doch absolut abfuck. Da hat doch auch keiner Bock dran zu arbeiten.
Es enthält zwei Easter-Eggs, ca. sieben Sekunden in dem Video, das Emblem für Task Force 141.
Deswegen fühlen sich die ganzen Games auch so seelenlos vom Fließband an, weil die kreativen Leute halt Dienst nach Vorschriften machen.
Das kann gesehen werden. Das ist die internationale Special-Opps-Team, die in den letzten Modern Warfare-Games gesehen wurden.
Außerdem hat Industrie-Insider Tom Henderson ein Set von Koordinaten in dem Teaser beigetragen.
Sie sehen sich nach Singapur an. Activision hat noch nicht viel über das Spiel gesagt.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Modern Warfare 2 und die neue Warzone-Experienz mit dabei sind,
aber von der Grunde nach oben gebaut und mit groundbreaking Innovationen ausgeführt sind.
Aber das war das einzige offizielle Kommentar, das mit dem Spiel ausgeführt wurde.
Moment, Moment. Da kann nichts China-Kritisches drin sein in dem Game. Dann kommt nämlich Tencent an und sagt
Nee, nee Leute, Activision Blizzard, das macht ihr mal schön nicht. Wo kämen wir denn da hin, wenn da irgendwas China-Kritisches drin wäre?
Star Wars Jedi Fallen Order 2 ist reportedly a PC in Next-Gen-Only-Title.
This rumor stems from insider Jeff Grubb, who stated on a...
Next-Gen-Only? Wollt ihr... Leute, die Next-Gen-Konsolen sind schon wieder zwei Jahre alt.
Kann man da wirklich von Next-Gen sprechen? Wann kam die PS5 raus?
2000... Okay, eineinhalb Jahre. Also, kann man noch von Next-Gen sprechen, wenn die Hardware schon eineinhalb Jahre raus ist?
Ich denke nicht. Wie seht ihr das Chat? Also für mich ist Next-Gen... Spätestens...
Spätestens zu Release ist es eigentlich nicht mehr Next-Gen.
Aber eineinhalb Jahre nach Release ist es definitiv nicht mehr Next-Gen.
Es ist aktuelle Current-Gen. Durch die schlechte Verfügbarkeit.
Ich denke, die meisten Leute, die eine PS5 haben wollen, haben mittlerweile eine PS5.
Aber streng genommen ist das nach Release nicht Next-Gen.
Ich meine, gerade zu Xbox 360 hat man sehr lang Next-Gen gesagt.
Xbox 360 kam wann raus? 2006 oder so?
Und 2005... Man hat quasi noch drei, vier Jahre Next-Gen gesagt zu Xbox 360.
Leute, ich habe es mir kurz überlegt.
Ihr wisst, ich habe, glaube ich, kaum ein Game die letzten Jahre so hart und lang am Stück gekreinet wie Overwatch.
Immerhin Top 500 Season 1, ja?
Ich habe es mir kurz überlegt.
Ich habe es mir kurz über toilert.
Ich habe es mir kurz über защo.
was sie gemacht haben ist, von 6 auf 5 Mann verringert, wie gut sich das am Ende spielt,
weiß ich nicht, ich könnte mir vorstellen, das wird schon passen. Es gibt einen neuen
Held, einen neuen Spielmodus und irgendwie eine neue Map oder sowas. Das ist in anderen
Games ein Season-Update, wenn überhaupt. Und das, was ich bisher vom PvE und dem Story-Modus
gesehen habe, das war ja noch nicht viel, aber das, was man gesehen hat, sieht aus wie
ein Zwei-Mann-Modder-Projekt. Also nicht irgendwie super, wie soll ich sagen, nicht jetzt irgendwie,
dass man sagt, boah, das ist ja quasi so atmosphärisch und eigene Welt und sonst wie, das sah aus
wie ein Zwei-Mann-Modder-Projekt, was man bisher gesehen hat vom Singleplayer. Und Overwatch
rankt an so vielen Stellen. Von Sachen wie Balancing fangen wir mal gar nicht an. Overwatch
Balancing, ich hab's schon oft gesagt, ist typisches Blizzard-Balancing. Hey, was ist
denn das? Overwatch Balancing ist typisches Blizzard-Balancing. Blizzard-Balancing sieht
so aus. Also keine Ahnung. Nehmen wir mal für einen Held, das Spiel kommt raus, Held
ist OP. Held ist OP. Hier, hier ist OP. So, Held ist OP, Held ist OP, erster Patch kommt,
Held is kacke. Held is kacke, Held is kacke, Held ist kacke, Held is kacke, Held is kacke,
Held is kacke, Held ist kacke. Irgendwann kommt Rework, Held ist OP, Held is OP, Held
is OP, Held ist OP. Nerf, Held ist wieder mega kacke, mega, dass ist Blizzard-Balancing.
das ist blizzard balance, die machen das in allen games, die kriegen das nicht geschissen
und
Keine ahnung, also davon will ich hier gar nicht mehr anfangen, das ist ein generelles problem
was die, was die in Overwatch dann anfangen an haben
Was, was ich viel blöder finde ist, dass blizzard beispielsweise immer gesagt hat, Overwatch soll hier das neue, der neue e-sport hit werden, Null
Es ist überhaupt nicht, Overwatch League ist so unbedeutend wie nie zuvor und es gibt keine außer Overwatch League
jetzt ich weiß, dass es Contenders gibt, aber mal ehrlich, Contenders wird nirgendswo richtig geworben, Contenders guckt kein, Contenders juckt keinen
Jedes regional, also wenn die, wenn die skandinavischen länder, ein, ein, ein, was weiß ich, King of
Skandinavia CS Turnier machen, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob sowas gibt, aber gehen wir mal von aus
Das hat 20 mal mehr Viewer als Overwatch Contenders
Und das ist irgendein Regionalevent, Contenders ist theoretisch Tier 2
Also A-Tier, was bescheuert ist, weil das gibt es in Overwatch nicht
So, also es gibt, es gibt in Overwatch kein e-sport außerhalb Overwatch League
Und es gibt dementsprechend kein Tier 2, kein Tier 3, kein Nachwuchs, nichts
Es ist dead as fuck im e-sport, Overwatch
Obwohl Blizzard das groß als der nächsten e-sport shit angekündigt hat, die könnten, die hätten so unglaublich viel für dieses Game machen können
Automatisch generierte Ingame-Weeklies zum Beispiel, Turniere, hätte man ohne Probleme machen können
Es hätte auch nicht mal automatisch generiert sein müssen, ja
Also man hätte die ganze e-sport Geschichte, wenn man die dann machen möchte
Wenn man dann sagt, dieses Spiel soll in Richtung e-sport gehen, hätte man so viel mehr machen können
Es ist nicht so, dass es an Ideen da mangelt
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen möchte Blizzard nicht
So, dazu kommt, dass es kaum neuen Content gibt
Also wie gesagt, Ballern sind jetzt schon mal abgehakt, kaum neuen Content gibt
Der letzte Overwatch, wisst ihr wann der letzte Overwatch Shortfilm rausgekommen ist?
Das war glaube ich für, mit McCree und Echo
Sorry, sorry, McCree, oh nein
Das wäre ich gleich nicht McCree
Cassidy, sorry, nicht McCree, das war ja, das darf man ja gar nicht mehr sagen
Sonst sind die Leute triggert
Es war der letzte Kurzfilm, 2018, da hieß er aber noch so
Die haben weder Lore und Geschichte und Story gebracht
Für die Gelegenheitscasual Spieler, die stehen da zum größten Teil drauf
Ich muss sagen, ich fand die Overwatch Lore und die Kurzfilme richtig gut
Ich halte den Bastion Kurzfilm tatsächlich für eines der besten Dinger, die in dieser Richtung rausgekommen sind
Der Bastion Kurzfilm ist richtig gut, unabhängig davon, ob du Overwatch spielst oder nicht
Die anderen gingen auch so, aber der Bastion Kurzfilm, den fand ich richtig gut
Setke, ja
So, und
Dann hat Overwatch immer noch kaum, jetzt immer noch kaum Content
Die haben es irgendwie geschafft, in drei Jahren zwei Maps zu veröffentlichen und zwei Helden oder sowas
Vielleicht ein bisschen übertragen, vielleicht waren es auch drei, ja
Die Maps, die in dem Spiel drin sind, sind zu 50% immer noch Müll
Ja, ich sag nur 2CP Temple of Anubis oder sowas, das ist immer noch am Start
Es ist seriously eine Map mit Capture Points drin, oder Volskaya Industries
Es sind wirklich Maps mit Capture Points drin, wo der Spawn immer noch zwei Meter hinterm Capture Point ist
An sich ist Capture Point, ich weiß, das haben die rausgeschmissen, ja, aber hallo
Das Spiel ist 2016 oder so rausgekommen, warum ist das immer noch ein Ding in der heutigen Zeit
Das haben sie zum Glück jetzt rausgeschmissen, 2CP, gut, das liegt bestimmt aber auch daran, mit der Reduktion von 6 auf 5
2CP, der beschwachsinnigste Modus überhaupt
Eigentlich, eigentlich ist 2CP gar nicht schlecht, aber in Kombination mit den Maps ist es wirklich hängen geblieben
Nee, es ist keine Gründe, Overwatch 2 zu kaufen, weil der Multiplayer Part wird zwischen Overwatch 1 und Overwatch 2 geschert
Du kannst Overwatch 1 behalten, das kommt ja noch dazu
Ich glaub nur das Grafikupdate und der Singleplayer ist Overwatch 2 exklusiv
Warum gibt es eigentlich keine guten Maps mehr, tja, weil Blizzard anscheinend keine Shooter Maps bauen kann, ich weiß es nicht
Also generell muss ich sagen, die Overwatch Maps sind von Details her, Design her und so von der
Vom Artwork und allem sind die wirklich ganz gut
Aber vom Aufbau her und der Platzierung von Objectives und Capture Points, ich weiß nicht, ich finde das nicht gut
Die sind zum größten Teil auch zu linear
Du hast ja in Overwatch im Prinzip, gerade bei Assault und sowas hast du in Overwatch im Prinzip einen Weg, den du gehen kannst
Mit drei Choke Points zwischendurch, wo du deinen Kart durchpushen musst, also ich weiß nicht, also Maps waren noch nie
Aber die Hälfte der Maps von Overwatch kannst du eigentlich knicken und gäbe es in Overwatch ein Map Voting System
Könnte man davon ausgehen, dass 50% der Maps weggevotet werden
Tja, aber mir ist es ein absolutes Rätsel, wie man es schaffen kann, das riesen Potential, was in Overwatch drinnen steckte
So über die Jahre nicht zu nutzen, wie das Blizzard gemacht hat, keine Ahnung, verstehe ich nicht
Obwohl da so viele mega highly paid professionals sitzen, die eigentlich wissen, was sie machen
Tja, von technischer Seite aus und auch, wie gesagt, Grafikstil ist Overwatch wirklich ein saumäßig gutes Spiel
Also es gibt wenig und ich spiele Multiplayer-Spiele seit 56K, modernen Zeiten, Half-Life 1 online
Also ich habe einige Multiplayer-Spiele gesehen in den letzten Jahren
Und ich muss sagen, kein Spiel, also kein PvP-Multiplayer-Shooter hat sich so gut von der Netzwerkseite angefühlt wie Overwatch
Overwatch hat seine Probleme mit manchmal, dass Hits nicht registriert werden und sowas
Da kannst du aber im Prinzip nichts dagegen machen, wenn wirklich mal dummerweise irgendwas verloren geht
Das Problem hat jedes Game, aber in Overwatch ist insgesamt die Netzwerk-Performance das beste
Was ich kenne
Kein Game, sag mir irgendein Game, was da rankommt
Overwatch fühlt sich einfach gut an, rein vom Netzwerk-Multiplayer-Aspekt
Da laggt nichts, da zuggelt nichts, da hitreckt es in der Regel auch
Da wirst du nicht um die Ecke gekillt, da wirst du nicht irgendwie gehitted von Dingern, die du nicht sehen kannst
Das ist einfach gut gemacht
Da kannst du, da kannst du nichts sagen
Gut, Valorant weiß ich nicht, Valorant habe ich nicht gespielt
Das ist einfach gut
Und deswegen finde ich doppelt kacke, dass sie das eigentliche Potential in diesem Spiel irgendwie so links liegen lassen
Seid mal froh, dass sie kein Warcraft 4 rausgebracht haben
Guckt ihr mal an, was aus Warcraft 3 deforged geworden ist
Stell dir mal vor, die gleichen Leute würden heute Warcraft 4 rausbringen
Die wissen immer, wie das funktioniert
Das ist ein bisschen wie bei DICE und Battlefield
Die haben ja mal gesagt, sie wissen gar nicht mehr, wie man ein Badgeist ausbauen kann
Mittlerweile wissen wir, wie man ein Badgeist ausbauen kann
Mittlerweile wissen wir, dass sie nicht mehr wissen, wie man ein Badgeist ausbauen kann
Sie wissen auch nicht mehr, wie man ein Battlefield ausbauen kann
Das war nicht gelogen, das stimmt
Und so ähnlich stelle ich mir mal Blizzard auch vor
Die haben keine Ahnung mehr, wie man ein gutes Warcraft 4 machen würde
Bei StarCraft wurschteln sie sich immer wieder
Bei StarCraft wurschteln sie sich ja auch ab seit 10 Jahren
Die haben keine Ahnung mehr, wie man ein gutes Warcraft 4 machen würde
nicht lesbisch sein. Keine Ahnung, du kannst das Twitter nicht recht machen, das ist unmöglich.
Du hast immer genug Leute, aber ich meine, die verdienen ja auch viele auf Twitter anscheinend
ihr Geld mit empört sein und sich darüber aufregen. Es wirklich Probleme machen, wo
keine Sinn.
According to the game's directive.
Letztendlich kann man immer sagen, künstlerische Freiheit. Und ich bin auch damit, die sollen
die sein, was für das Game gut ist. Die sollen die sein, was für das Game gut ist und fertig
aus und gut ist. Umgedrehter Fall war es, wo sich drüber aufgeregt wurde von der anderen
Seite jetzt auf Twitter, dass es jetzt in der Herr der Ringe Serie eine schwarze Zwergenprinzessin
gibt oder sowas in der Richtung. Da haben sich die Leute auch drüber aufgeregt und
da wurde dann darauf geantwortet, ja, künstlerische Freiheit. Ja, was denn, jetzt kann ich einmal
so sagen und einmal so sagen. Ich bin der Meinung, die Leute, die eine kreative Freiheit
über ein Produkt haben, sollen erstmal das machen, nämlich dafür sorgen, dass da ein
gutes Produkt bei rauskommt. Das ist das Wichtigste, auch für mich als Käufer. Das
was ich kaufe, das Negativbeispiel ist Battlefield 2042. Battlefield 2042 ist ein scheiß Game.
Es macht es nicht besser, dadurch, dass jetzt vielleicht dort alle möglichen Leute repräsentiert
sind. Das erste, was gut sein muss, ist das Game. Und das ist es bei Battlefield 2042
nicht. Also es ist dadurch weder besser noch schlechter. Oh man, aber Twitter, Alter, Twitter
ist bei uns bei diesem Thema echt komplett lost. Ja, da bin ich mal gespannt. Da bin
ich mal gespannt. Der PvE Modus ist das, was es reißen muss für das Game. Das ist das
einzige, was irgendwie eine Kaufberechtigung hat. Da habe ich meine Zweifel, dass das,
also ich meine die Hitboxen von Overwatch sind ja schon nicht verkehrt, aber dass man
hier durchschießen kann zwischen Ekos Flügel und dem... Na gut, die hat vorher schon geschossen.
Aber...
Ja.
The Game Showcase.
The event will take place on Sunday, June 12th at 10 a.m.
Pacific Time.
According to their official press release, the show will feature amazing titles
coming from Xbox Game Studios, Bethesda and their various partners.
Due to the event's space-themed branding, fans are speculating
that the highly anticipated sci-fi RPG Starfield from Bethesda
will make an appearance.
This lines up with the studio's usual release schedule.
Their games are typically showcased in the summer before their winter release.
Apex Legends, Season 13, dubbed Saviors, begins in early May.
Hä, was hat denn der Master Chief jetzt mit, ähm...
Ach, Moment, die haben die ja gekauft!
Ich hab's schon wieder verdrängt.
Die haben die ja gekauft.
Keg-Wade, Alter.
Das vergesse ich immer wieder.
Week players were treated to the launch trailer.
Und bald, und bald auch Activision.
It introduced a brand new legend named Newcastle.
His full ability set is unknown, though the trailer does show him
deploying an energy shield that can rotate on the spot.
He also appears to deploy a second barrier while...
Gibt es, gibt es Mops in Apex Legends?
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Gibt, gibt es, gibt es Monster in Apex Legends, ja?
Und, und was bringt das, wenn man die killt?
...while reviving a fallen teammate.
Significant changes to D-Rank system are rumored for this new season.
It's believed that players will be able to D-Rank to lower tiers.
This new system is supposedly going to emphasize skill and teamwork.
Map changes appear to be coming to Stormpoint, the game's latest addition.
Players expect this new season to drop on May 10th,
but no official confirmation has been shared yet.
Sony announced their PlayStation Now and...
Ich würde auch immer,
ich würde auch immer in so einem Kriegsgebiet in einem Korsett rumlaufen.
Das ist, glaube ich, das Allerbeste, was man da anziehen kann.
Sony announced their PlayStation Now and PlayStation Plus services are merging in June.
This prompted users to buy both services, so...
Die wollen, die wollen halt einfach ein bisschen was vom Xbox Game Pass abhaben,
beziehungsweise haben festgestellt, die haben nichts Vergleichbares.
Und sie werden wahrscheinlich auch nichts Vergleichbares haben.
...but they would be automatically upgraded to the highest tier of PlayStation Plus once it goes live.
This is a roundabout way of getting the highest tier for a much lower cost.
However, Sony caught on to this tactic quickly and is now blocking the method.
Users report that their console...
Geil!
Gebetet!
...cards and consoles are blocked from stacking the services.
You'll need to fork over the full $120 for an annual membership.
Ja.
Zombie Survival Game Dying Light 2 got a critical update.
The game has received a new Game Plus option and new mutated enemies.
New Game Plus allows players to replay the campaign with altered game mechanics.
The changes include tweaked enemy behavior, additional objectives on the map,
new parkour challenges and more.
The update also adds the mutated infected mission.
It features new goon variants on top of the new content.
This update fixes some bugs and...
Spielt das jemand noch aktiv?
Ich hab gelesen, ich hab letztens, ich glaub in irgendeinem Reddit-Thread gelesen,
dass das Endgame, wenn man das so nennen kann, äußerst, also mega repetitive sein muss.
...glitches, while also making some UI improvements.
The Survival Zombie Looter, DayZ, has beaten its all-time peak player count record on Steam this week,
as captured by the Steam Tra-
Was?
Warum hat DayZ auf einmal wieder, wieder Spieler?
Ich dachte, das ist seit vier Jahren out.
...website, the new record stands at 50-
The fuck?
Wie jetzt?
Waren, waren irgendwelche Streamer, Turniere oder was?
...the 8,240.
There doesn't seem to be an obvious reason as to why the player count has shot up.
Some fans attribute the success to the game's latest update,
which adds new weapons like the CR-550 Bolt Action Rifle and the 308 Longhorn Pistol.
Not to mention all of the latest bug fixes.
Much to the disappointment of Ubisoft fans everywhere,
the publisher has shut down servers and online support for 90 of their games.
Some of them include popular titles like Assassin's Creed 2, Far Cry Blood Dragon and-
Assassin's Creed 2 hatte einen Online-Modus?
Ach stimmt, die hatten mit den Add-ons dieses Jahr, gut, das hat eh keiner gespielt.
...Fame and Legends.
This update also affects achievements and item unlocks.
For example, in Assassin's Creed Brotherhood, players must complete an online challenge to unlock certain cosmetics.
Without the servers, this will become impossible.
And while this news is disappointing for anyone who likes old school titles,
well, it doesn't affect Ubisoft's newest or current releases.
Ja, das wär ja noch schöner.
Tja, so ist es halt.
Denn heute sind Games halt zum größten Teil ein Service.
Und das wird in Zukunft noch deutlich mehr Games so gehen.
Und gerade Games mit Always-On-Funktionen...
...die werden einfach komplett nicht mehr funktionieren.
Alien Isolation, die Survival-Horror-Game von Creative Assembly, bekommt eine Behind-the-Scenes-Novel.
Andy Kelly, ein Experten-Writer, der mit Vice, PC-Gamer und The Guardian gearbeitet hat,
schreibt eine Zusammenarbeit-Novel, die Perfekt-Organism ist.
Ja, dass die die Server für all... das finde ich auch nicht schlimm.
Aber müssen wir mal gucken, was da alles dabei ist.
Es ist aber halt blöd, dass du Xbox-Achievements und sowas da dran gebunden hast, ja?
Es gibt ja Leute, die wollen, die sind so richtig Completionist-mäßig unterwegs.
Die holen sich Games nur, um so halt auf 1200 Gamerscore oder was auch Maximum in den Games ist, zu spielen.
Und das geht jetzt halt nicht mehr.
Das ist schon doof.
Dann könnten sie es wenigstens so machen, dass sich automatisch die Multiplayer-Achievements jetzt...
...äh...
...entlocken lassen.
Dann werden zwar alle sagen, die für die Multiplayer-Achievements gecriedet haben, unfairer Scheiß,
aber besser als Achievements, die nie wieder jemals erreichbar sind.
The publishing of this novel is entirely fan-funded.
So far, Kelly has raised 38% of his goal.
Before we move on to today's final topic, let us know your thoughts on the new Battlefield 2042 datamines.
Are you hoping for another...
NEIN!
Ich hoffe für gar nichts!
Hallo, ein Specialist ohne Map und ein paar neue Icons!
Wahnsinn!
No map or do you want something different from Season 1?
Ich habe keine Zeit, in letzter Zeit irgendwie großartig was anderes zu machen als...
...Arbeiten, Streamsorn, ab und zu mal ein YouTube-Video zu machen, bei mir daheim am Haus rumzubauen,
aufzuräumen, Technik hier zu machen und alle möglich anderen Kram.
Ich komme nicht dazu, mich da in neue Spiele großartig...
...einzuarbeiten.
Da denke ich mir manchmal, es wäre sehr nice, wenn ich 15 wäre oder 16 oder so, wieder.
Da habe ich dann...
Da konnte ich noch 16 Stunden am Tag sitzen und spielen, wenn ich wollte.
Heute tut mir der Arsch weh.
Haha, nach 4 Stunden oder so.
Kacibuzz, Alter.
Was ist aus dem Zertifikat geworden?
Das hat funktioniert, aber es wurde ausgetauscht unter 24 Stunden vom Ablauf.
Der Friseur, ja.
Mit dem habe ich vereinzelt in letzter Zeit noch Kontakt, ja.
Wir haben leider keine Spiele aktuell, die man zusammenspielen kann.
Aber sonst klar habe ich mit dem Friseur noch Kontakt.
Ich meine, ich kannte den Friseur ja auch schon lange vor YouTube.
Also warum sollte ich keinen Kontakt mehr haben mit dem?
Es ist äußerst selten.
Letztes Jahr gar nicht mehr.
Aber es liegt auch zum größten Teil an mir.
Ich meine, ich könnte mich auch mal wieder melden.
Aber ich bin halt Pepega Social Kerl.
Bebega.
Gibt es das eigentlich?
Bebega?
War klar, natürlich gibt es Bebega.
Das ist aber ziemlich bescheuert, die Emotes.
Zum Krieger habe ich eigentlich so gut wie keinen Kontakt mehr.
Ich glaube, das letzte Mal war irgendwie...
Als letztes Mal, wo ich mit dem Krieger gesprochen habe,
ist bestimmt schon vier Jahre her.
Ab und zu mal auf Twitter ein bisschen.
Aber wir haben auch wenig Überschneidungen.
Ich habe eben letztens ins Stream reingeguckt,
da hat England ein komisches Jäger-Game gespielt,
wo er mit der Hirschflöte durch den Wald gelaufen ist
und dann Hirsche abgesnippert hat und sowas.
Da habe ich gesagt, was zum Teufel spielt der denn da?
Ja, ja, doch, genau das war es.
Jetzt erinnere ich mich wieder an den Titel.
Irgend so ein Jäger-Game hat er gespielt.
Commander Krieger Aim.
Das war Zeit, ne?
Du musstest mal ein German Taters Re-Watch machen.
Das ist so outdated, die Videos.
Weiß nicht, was man da re-watchen soll.
Das Spiel ist schön zum Entspannen.
Okay, weiß ich.
Ich fand es jetzt nicht so spannend.
Oder entspannend oder überhaupt so, dass ich das...
Hat jemand mal das da ausprobiert?
Das finde ich, sieht richtig nice.
Das ist ein deutsches Game.
Das finde ich, sieht richtig nice aus für ein entspannendes Game.
Ist ganz nice.
Ja, habe ich auch.
Ich habe letztens in GameStar Review gesehen.
Haben wir auch gesagt, das ist ein richtig nice Entspannungs-Game.
Ich weiß es, deswegen habe ich mir das auch aufgefallen, weil es gerade released wurde.
So ein Entspannungs-Game könnte ich mir schon auch geben.
Das könnte ich auch super als Hintergrund-Gameplay nehmen.
Einfach weil, wenn ich bei irgendwas habe, wo man eigentlich einfach nur ein bisschen nebenbei zuhören muss, ist das wunderbar.
So, was haben wir denn als...
Was gibt es eigentlich neu...
Ich will nicht Rohrbauer, ich will wissen, haben die was anderes?
Vertriebstrainerin, Rezeptionisten, Rohrleitungsbau, IT-Administ...
Das haben wir schon geguckt, oder?
Ah ja, das waren die mit den UniFi Access Points.
Leute, ich bin mit meinem UniFi Zeug nicht mehr zufrieden.
Ich bin mir noch unschlüssig, ob ich mal was anderes ausprobieren sollte.
Ich bin... also, es gibt zwei Sachen, warum ich mit meinem UniFi Zeug noch mal glücklich bin.
Was ist das, was du mit dem UniFi Zeug auf der Webseite aufmachst?
Das erste ist, weil ich aus irgendwelchen nicht verständlichen Gründen Verbindungsabbrüche habe mit meinem...
Oder nicht nur mit meinem iPhone, mit den iPads und dem iPhone.
Verbindungsabbrüche insofern, dass du machst deine Webseite auf und es dauert einfach 10 Sekunden, bis er sich richtig zum Access Point connectet hat.
Verstehe ich nicht, warum. Keine Ahnung. Ist nicht immer so, ist selten so, aber es nervt.
Die Access Points sind auch, weiß nicht, merkwürdig, was Ausleuchtung angeht.
Ich mein, mein Haus ist nicht sonderlich groß hier.
Das ist jetzt nicht, dass es irgendwie eine 500 Quadratmeter Villa wäre oder so.
Es ist halt Keller, Erdgeschoss, erster Stock, Dach.
So, und ich habe im Erdgeschoss, ich habe im Keller einen Access Point.
Im Erdgeschoss.
Im ersten Stock.
Wahrscheinlich bräuchte ich den im Erdgeschoss gar nicht.
Denke ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ich habe auch extra die Wi-Fi Sende, Sendestärke runtergestellt, dass sich das nicht so sehr übernimmt.
So, und dann habe ich noch einen vierten Access Point, der ist am Fenster raus zur Terrasse, dass ich auch quasi ein bisschen Gartenwählern habe.
Ich finde es allein schon bescheuert, dass ich vier Access Points oder drei bis vier Access Points überhaupt brauche.
Ich meine, das ist ja Oldschool Haus mit fetten Wänden und so, das ist nicht einfach Ami-Holz-Bauweise oder so.
Das ist schon massiv. Was du auch noch nicht weißt.
Oder eigentlich hat es der Ur-Ur-Ur-Oppa gebaut, der dann nach Südafrika abgehauen ist.
Und das gefällt mir nicht.
Und was mir auch nicht gefällt ist, dass die ein Feature, dass den ein Feature fehlt, was ich unbedingt haben will.
Nämlich extra Passwörter für IoT-Clients.
Also dass du beispielsweise eine WLAN-Steckdose, WLAN-LED-Lampe, dass du der ein eigenes WLAN-Passwort geben kannst.
Weil dann kannst du die Lampe auch wegschmeißen, das löschen und dann liegt dein WLAN-Passwort nicht im Müll.
Das ist immer noch was, was mir überhaupt nicht vom Verfahren gefällt, wie IoT-Geräte.
In der Regel betrieben werden, dass man ein WLAN-Passwort hat, wo alles reinkommt.
Und sobald du das Gerät wegschmeißt, liegt dein WLAN-Passwort im Müll.
Das finde ich kacke.
Und UniFi hat dieses Feature nicht.
Zu ziemlich jeder andere etwas teurere, sogar Mikrotik, Anbieter von WLAN-Hardware hat das.
Doch, die meisten haben das.
Die meisten.
Also wenn man jetzt mal von den billigen Dingern ab sieht, ja, also von irgendwelchen unmanagedotion-TPLinks,
der bUEt – Winrar – auch noch
Sogar Mikrotik, Anbieter von WLAN-Hardware hat das.
Doch, die meisten haben das.
Wenn man jetzt mal von den billigen Dingern absieht,
also von irgendwelchen unmanaged TP-Link-Dingern,
oder unmanaged gibt es ja bei Access Points nicht,
von irgendwelchen TP-Link-Dingern oder Netgeedingern,
also wenn man rein von Konsumerzeug absieht,
Mikrotik hat es, Cisco hat es, Aruba hat es,
Ruckus hat es, wie auch immer man die ausspricht.
Also klar, die sind alle nicht billig
und die sind zum größten Teil auch noch teurer als UniFi,
außer Mikrotik, Mikrotik hat es auch
und der Kram ist ähnlich teuer bzw. günstiger als UniFi Sachen.
Aber ich, so gern ich Mikrotik habe, was Switcher und Router angeht,
von den Mikrotik Access Points bin ich nicht sonderlich überzeugt.
Lancom hat es auch, ja.
OpenWrt hat es mittlerweile auch.
Die haben einen Pull-Request, den kann man sich selbst merchen
oder man wartet bis sie den gemercht haben.
OpenWrt hat es mittlerweile theoretisch bald.
Wir sind gerade dabei, das zu merchen.
Dann haben sie es auch.
Und damit kannst du für jedes WLAN-Endgerät
ein eigenes WLAN-Passwort vergeben.
Fortinet hat es bestimmt auch.
Es haben im Prinzip alle etwas teureren Anbieter, außer UniFi.
Und es gibt auch tausende Threads.
Es gibt sogar jemand, der das selbst gebaut hat
mit Custom-Config für UniFi Access Points.
Es gibt tausende Threads, Reddit offizielles UniFi Forum,
dass sie sagen, Leute, das ist ein echt wichtiges Feature,
das brauchen wir gerade für IoT Sachen,
aber die wollen nicht, die haben keinen Bock.
Und das ist ein Feature, was ich wirklich gerne hätte.
Ja.
Nur mal so, nebenbei angemerkt.
Jahr 2022, aber der letzte Status ist von diesem Jahr,
dass es gerade bei dem Core-Developer-Team ist
Ende letzten Jahres, und die das merken wollen.
Im Zweifelsfall kann man das aber auch selbst merken,
wenn man will.
Ich habe noch nie eine eigene Open-WRT-Version gebaut.
Hock.
Richtig, richtige MVPs hier.
Dazu kann man bloß sagen.
Nice, nice, nice.
Kann man die nicht mit Open-WRT flashen, teilweise.
Manche musst du aufschrauben.
Aber nachdem Open-WRT offiziell das noch nicht hat,
müsste ich mir Open-WRT selbst kompilieren.
Das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Da bin ich nicht sonderlich scharf drauf.
Ich bin gerade am Überlegen, ob ich mir nicht auf eBay
mal einen älteren, was weiß ich,
Ruckus oder sonst was Access-Point kaufe für ein paar Euro
und das mal ausprobieren, ob das was taugt.
Ja, ja, das bringt dir aber nichts, wenn Open-WRT,
also ich kenne die Anleitung, wie man das flasht.
Manche musst du aufschrauben und sogar anlöten.
Aber das bringt mir nichts, wenn die Open-WRT-Version
das Feature, was ich noch nicht drin hat.
Weil selbst kompilieren möchte ich ehrlich gesagt
Open-WRT nicht.
Eine was?
Eine MSI?
Was ist das?
Mobile Security?
Multi-Session?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was MSI ist.
MSI ist immer noch ein gutes Stichwort, Leute.
Lass mich mal kurz was ausprobieren.
Ich muss mal kurz was checken.
MSI Germany?
Ähm...
Ich bin immer noch gebannt.
Mann, warum?
Warum entbannen die mich nicht?
Ich bin immer noch gebannt.
Und ich weiß einfach nicht, warum.
Und sie sagen es mir auch nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum.
Ich weiß es nicht, was ich gemacht habe.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß es wirklich nicht.
Du hättest zwei neue Videos.
Graphics.
Boah, das ist ganz schön lang.
Gucken wir uns nicht jetzt an.
Ich mache das mal auf, vielleicht gucken wir uns irgendwann demnächst an.
Meine Tabs sind so klein, dass ich die Tabs nicht mehr mal anklicken kann.
Bestimmt, das wird es sein.
Das wäre es, ja.
Ich glaube nicht, dass der an den MSI Deutschland-Accounten besser sich dafür interessiert.
Ach so, ein Microsoft-Installer.
Ich habe es nicht in Zusammenhang gebracht mit WLAN jetzt.
Das hat aber mit WLAN nichts zu tun.
Ich habe hier gerade etwas über WLAN erzählt.
So, was haben wir sonst noch zu gucken?
EA wird immer schlimmer, neun Minuten.
Okay, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, warum EA immer schlimmer wird.
Ich meine, viel schlimmer kann es ja eigentlich nicht sein.
Aber ich kenne übrigens den Channel auch nicht, keine Ahnung.
Ja, das ist so.
Aber danach haben sie gesagt, EA ist jetzt Consumer First und wir werden uns bessern.
Und sie haben sich nicht gebessert und das haben sie eigentlich noch schlimmer gemacht.
Aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen werden sie nicht mehr die meistgehasste Firma.
Das liegt aber nicht so sehr daran, dass EA besser geworden ist,
sondern dass die anderen aufgeholt haben im Schlechtsein.
In den USA gewählt.
Bei mir damals auf dem Schulhof hieß es, kauft keine EA-Spiele,
denn EA ist der Teufel der Gaming-Branche.
Was soll ich sagen?
Ich persönlich habe mich an dieses Credo immer gehalten.
Aber meine lieben Jünger, auch ich habe gesündigt.
Nämlich 2018.
Damals kaufte ich bei meinem späteren Partner MMOGA Star Wars Battlefront.
Ist das Text to Speech?
Moment.
Hört euch das mal an, MMOGA.
Das hört sich an wie Text to Speech, Alter.
Star Wars Battlefront 2.
Ich hatte zu dem besagten Tag die Möglichkeit, mir für 3 Euro einen Döner zu kaufen.
Ja, damals waren einige Döner-Läden noch ein bisschen günstiger als heute in Berlin.
Oder halt...
Oh, cringe.
Das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Sorry.
Nee.
Das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
So, was kann man uns sonst noch anschauen?
Ja, nee.
Es heißt nicht, das Video kann tatsächlich richtig gut sein.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber manchmal habe ich das Verlangen, Videos nicht anzugucken.
Oh.
Ich helfe Jugendlichen mit Essstörungen.
Zählt, wenn man zu viel isst, auch als Essstörung?
Was ist denn, Leute?
Ihr keck wartet zu sehr im Chat.
Wollen wir es uns doch angucken, das Video?
Wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt das sehen, dann können wir es uns angucken.
Nein.
Keck wartet.
Okay.
Ja, dann keck wartet doch auch nicht so viel.
Oh Gott.
Jetzt steht Herr Kuchen vor ihnen.
als würd's schmecken, dann würd ich ihn jetzt einfach futtern.
Was geht innen durch den Kopf?
Das ist auch so eine typische Psychologenfrage, alter.
Der Label-Champ ist noch nicht done, nee.
Das ist so eine typische, so eine typische Psychologenfrage.
Wie geht das ihnen dabei?
Ah, Monte-Reaction-Schau, nee, jetzt nicht.
So, crazy new storage.
Open up, das wollte ich mir angucken.
Irgendein Typ hat anscheinend einen
Mee-Roboter, heißt das glaube ich korrekterweise.
Oder umgebaut mit einem Raspberry Pi oder so was.
Das wollte ich mir mal angucken.
Wahrscheinlich werde ich so was nicht in meinen Garten packen,
weil mein Garten ist viel zu unordentlich, dort irgendein Mee-Roboter
robotieren zu lassen.
Schauen wir mal, wie der das gebaut hat.
Aha, 0815 Generic Intro-Musik.
Pasa-Griert von seinem eigenen Mee-Roboter.
Das wäre tatsächlich irgendeine Story von irgendeinem billigen Splatter-Film.
Ja.
Mee-Roboter des Grauens oder irgendwie.
Mee, Mee. Der Horror in meinem Garten oder irgendwie so was.
Final Destination 69.
Mee-Roboter der Verdammnis, das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Mich würde ja mal interessieren, hat er das hinbekommen mit
Kabeln oder geht das irgendwie über GPS oder so?
Das ist was, was mich bei Mee-Robotern immer abgeschreckt hat,
dass man irgendwelche Kabel im Garten verlegen muss.
Wobei GPS halt so eine Sache ist.
GPS ist halt eigentlich.
Nicht genau dafür.
Ach so, GPS, GPS.
Gut, dass wir drüber gesprochen haben.
Eigentlich ist GPS nicht zentimetergenau, zumindest die zivile Version.
Ok, schauen wir mal.
Dr.
Frasher, moin.
Wie machen die das eigentlich, die Mee-Roboter?
Haben die einen Behälter?
Dann werden die ja instant voll
oder lassen sie das Gemähte einfach auf dem Gras liegen.
Und wenn die das liegen lassen,
muss man das danach noch zusammenrechen oder
oder verwest das dann mit der Zeit,
weil weil man immer nur ein bisschen schneidet.
Ok.
Dass die spawnen, ach so.
Logisch.
Schauen wir mal, wie er das gebaut hat.
Ist das ein Deutscher?
Dieser Chat ist jetzt deutsch.
Was für einen GPS?
RTK, was?
GPS.
Was für ein Ding.
Echtzeit Kinematik.
Alter, 5 hat Begriff.
150 IQ+, die Echtzeit Kinematik ist in der Geodesie
ein Verfahren zur präzisen Bestimmung von Positionskone mit dem Satellitnavigation.
Das wird so.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die mir damit sagen wollten.
Geodesie, das ist doch irgendwie Längen und Breiten.
Also das ist irgendwie so.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Erdlandverteilung.
Die erste ist die Referenz an, die zweite der Rover, dessen Position durchdreht.
Da werden Genauigkeiten von 1 bis 2 Zentimeter.
Das ist ziemlich gut.
Damit damit kann man Rasen mähen.
Ja, die machen das irgendwie so, dass die von der Basisstation eine Antenne haben und
auf dem Roboter eine Antenne haben und dann irgendwie das darüber tatsächlich.
Ja, vielleicht kann man dann die Ungenauigkeiten irgendwie rausrechnen, wenn man beides empfängt.
Das ist auf jeden Fall 5 hat Kram.
Das ist das ist wirklich nur für wahnsinnig intelligente Leute.
Gibt es gibt es ESP 32 RTK GPS?
Okay, gibt es?
Nice, so jetzt erst mal gucken, wie er das gebaut hat.
Die tun immer so, als sind wir hier in Deutschland super effizient und und super genau und sonst
was.
Die waren alle noch nicht hier.
Also ich meine, wir mögen vielleicht, wir mögen vielleicht in vielen Sachen übergenau
sein, aber effizient würde ich mal bezweifeln, dass wir mit unserer Bürokratie wahnsinnig
effizient sind.
Ich meine, wenn man sich jetzt, wenn man sich jetzt zum Beispiel nimmt, keine Ahnung, ich
kann mich noch dran erinnern, zum Beispiel, als ich in Türkei mal im Urlaub war, wenn
da ein Bus gekommen ist, dann war das eher so nice to have, wenn der Bus innerhalb so
des Tages, wo er auf dem Plan steht, auch kommt oder sowas.
Also natürlich, man kann sich immer noch negativ, negativ Beispiele nehmen, wo alles
noch schlechter funktioniert, aber ich soll sich mal die Bahn angucken und sowas.
Also das finde ich schon mal richtig gut, ganz ehrlich, diese Sachen mit Kabel legen
finde ich richtig hängen geblieben.
Ohne Kabel würde ich mir sowas vielleicht auch mal überlegen, wobei ich glaube, das
funktioniert nur mit Garten, wo glatt ist, bei mir ist auch mal die eine oder andere
Wurzel im Weg vor einem Baum, ich glaube damit funktioniert das nicht richtig.
Ratog sagt, durchlaufe gerade UK-Visa, ist genauso schlimm mit Bürokratie, okay.
Ja, genauso schlimm bedeutet ja dann aber auch, man könnte da einiges verbessern, auch
bei uns.
Ich meine, wenn ich mir überlege, was du in Deutschland teilweise machen willst, wenn
du eine Firma gründen willst und wenn du irgendwas rausbringen willst an Produkten,
da wundert mich nicht, dass viele Leute sagen, ja okay, wir designen das vielleicht hier,
aber produzieren lassen, tun wir das dann irgendwie in China, Vietnam oder sonst wo.
Hier ist da teilweise absoluter Wahnsinn, was du machen musst.
Mich fackt es übelst ab, dass ich Zwangsmitglied sein muss in der IHK zum Beispiel, ich muss
der IHK regelmäßig Geld überweisen, nur weil ich einen Gewerbe angemeldet habe.
Es hat keinen Sinn, es bringt mir nichts, ich will nichts von denen, es kostet einfach
nur Geld, aber ich muss es machen.
Wie viel weiß ich gerade aus dem Kopf, nicht so viel, 50 Euro oder so und auch, ich glaube
auch nur im Jahr oder im halben Jahr oder irgendwie sowas, ich weiß es gar nicht, ich
glaube 50 Euro, es ist nicht viel, aber doch, doch, ich habe einen Vorteil davon, ich bekomme
regelmäßig die IHK Woche oder wie diese, wie dieser IHK Zeitschrift, ich weiß gar nicht
wie dieses Ding heißt, ich schmeiße das immer weg, ich bekomme regelmäßig das IHK Magazin,
jawoll, das brauche ich aber, ganz wichtig, das wandert immer direkt in Müll, das kommt
gar nicht in die Wohnung mit rein.
Ne, ich bin nicht unter 6000 Euro Umsatz, ich muss bezahlen.
Max ist Millionär, schön wärs, ganz ehrlich Leute, wenn ich Millionär wäre, wisst ihr
was ich ändern würde an meinem Leben, soll ich euch sagen, was würde ich anders machen,
wenn ich Millionär wäre?
Gar nichts, korrekt, ich würde wahrscheinlich gar nichts anders machen, Twitter kaufen,
da müsste ich aber schon ziemlich krasser Millionär sein, drei Tage in der Woche arbeiten,
das vielleicht, aber im Großen und Ganzen würde ich wahrscheinlich gar nichts machen,
also gar nichts ändern.
Das sieht man nämlich schon daran, dass mein Kontostand am Ende des Monats nicht plus
minus Null ist, also ist es jetzt nicht so, dass ich nicht hinkommen würde und es ist
auch nicht so, als dass ich mir, dass mein Kontostand am Ende des Monats nicht plus minus
Null ist, also ist es jetzt nicht so, dass ich nicht hinkommen würde und es ist auch
nicht so, als dass ich mir irgendwelche Sachen, wo ich sage, oh das wollte ich schon immer
mal machen oder so dass ich das dass ich das nicht mache weil ich zu wenig geld
habe oder so es ist ich komme echt gut klar mit dem wie es aktuell ist und
deswegen ich doch ich weiß was ich machen würde ich würde mir noch mehr
stonks kaufen
dass aus dem geld noch mehr geld wird
ja das ist ja schön für alle die nichts bezahlen müssen ich könnte mir endlich
respiratory pies leisten das ist richtig ja das hat ja elon mask wohl schon
gesagt er möchte dass die die sollen weniger geld bekommen die twitter
chefs würdest du vielleicht definitiv das würde ich tatsächlich machen ja
also wenn ich wirklich jetzt ein paar millionen hätte ich würde auf jeden
fall mehr spenden aber ich sage euch wie es ist ich habe das schon oft gesagt ihr
wisst dass ich ich habe vergessen wie sich das nennt ich mag also ich kann
anderen menschen nicht so viel abgewinnen ja also ich würde nicht für
soziale projekte spenden also nicht für solche soziale projekte die was mit
menschen zu tun haben ich würde für unser tierheim spenden oder für so was
in der richtung ja aber ich würde nicht für menschen spenden
juckt mich nicht aber ich würde tatsächlich mehr spenden wenn ich wenn
ich also hätte ich jetzt wirklich fünf millionen oder so vielleicht vielleicht
vielleicht würde ich mir auch würde ich mir auch ein anderes auto als dem opel
agila holen einfach nur weil es geht ich ich würde ich würde ja ich würde auf
jeden fall mehr spenden aber nicht an irgendwelche humanitären sozialen
projekte wobei tierheim ist ja auch was soziales aber nichts humanitäres das
geht mir am arsch vorbei aber ich würde für tierheimen spenden oder für irgendwie
für die tierhilfe oder sowas so dinge das ist mir deutlich lieber
bau doch den park vielleicht würde ich auf den park bauen keine ahnung aber
wozu den max fps park gibt es dann in frankfurt wobei das wäre doch was
frankfurt goethe straße am park ist der max fps park man merkt dass du jetzt
gerade nicht in der kirche bist warum ich bin nie in der kirche das ist
eigentlich für nice twitch call anstatt am pock also an die kirche spenden würde ich
definitiv nix ich würde wieder an die kirche spenden noch an irgendwelche
sozialen humanitären sachen was wie gesagt ich würde höchst an tierheimen
oder so was spenden war ich übrigens aktuell auch
ach so tja selbst ich ich war nie gläubig ganz ehrlich ich habe das letzte mal wo ich in der
kirche war das war keine ahnung da war ich wann macht man kommunion mit zehn oder so
weiß ich nicht das ist das letzte mal wo ich in der kirche gewesen bin und ich war noch nie
gläubig ich bin damals wisst ihr warum ich zur kommunie alter muss man gucken alter
kommunion wann macht man das 10 10 ja irgendwie mit 10 wisst ihr wisst ihr wisst ihr warum ich in
die kirche gegangen bin und und kommunion gemacht habe damals der einzige grund für geld richtig
genau einzig und allein für geld so sieht es aus ja ich habe damals über 1000 mark gekriegt an
spenden weiß ich wie man das nennt die gesamte verwandtschaft hat was da gelassen und da kam
ich mir mega reich vor damals ja richtig mark war das noch boomer ich bin 1984 geboren man
kann sich das vielleicht nicht vorstellen ich glaube ich bin ein richtig keine ahnung ein
richtig wirra hybrid aus boomer und summa also ich bin vom alter her boomer und von vielen sachen so
die man so über die jahre mitgenommen hat auch irgendwie boomer aber auf der anderen seite was
was twitch streaming und irgendwie irgendwelche neuen memes und so was angeht bin ich bin ich
summa also ich bin quasi ein weiß ich nicht ob es dafür ein wort gibt hybrid summa oder so
heute ist alles ab 30 boomer
ja hättest du besser gemacht also wie gesagt dass der einzige grund warum ich damals kommunion
gemacht habe in der kirche ist weil ich geld bekommen hab ich war nie gläubig bin ich war also
war ich nicht bin ich aktuell auch nicht und werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht sein man weiß ja
nie was passiert ich habe aber keine schmerzen damit wenn leute gläubig sind ich ich bin da
ansicht solange mich keiner bekehren möchte darf jeder machen was er will juckt mich auch
nicht ja wenn mir jetzt natürlich einer erzählen will so was weiß ich die jesus liebt liebt euch
leute die teilweise am südbahnhof in frankfurt rum eiern oder so was ja die gehen mir auf den
keks weil ich mal lasse mich in ruhe aber ansonsten ist mir das ist mir das egal so
lange mich die leute in ruhe lassen da weil man ehrlich ist ob ich jetzt an das fliegende
spaghetti monster glauben würde oder an irgendwie eine der größeren welt religion macht im prinzip
kein unterschied ist es alles ziemlich auf schwachsinn was aber witzig ist wenn du
irgendwas wenn du irgendeinen streng gläubigen fragst egal welche religion er angehört ob er
an das fliegende spaghetti monster glaubt er sagte hallo willst mich verarschen was eigentlich total
bescheuert ist so viel anders ist das jetzt gar nicht als das wo er an glaubt aber gut das ist
natürlich ein thema da kann kann man sich wahnsinnig kontrefflich darüber streiten soll jeder glauben
was er will ist mir echt wurscht so lange mich nicht bekehren will glaubst du dass wir in einer
simulation leben das kann gut sein das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen ob das so ist ja schwierig
es ist schwierig innerhalb einer simulation rauszubekommen ob du in einer simulation lebst
keine ahnung
kennst du das oh ja das kenne ich so wir gucken jetzt aber das video mal weiter
wir wollten wir wollten immer noch den den den mehroboter gucken fällt mir gerade ein also wir
sind irgendwie leicht leicht ab abgeschwiffen
jaja wautz tonic hast du recht was ich auch total bescheuert finde
also macht die musik nicht so laut moment steuern das kann
also das ist ja mal richtig frei fett du kannst einfach dein monitor im controller
steuern das ist ja mega das brauche ich moment wir das gemacht alter das ist ja mega nice dann
würde ich sogar mal rasen mähen der merkt sich quasi der macht eine map quasi draus
geil aber das das ist das was ich so eine map aufbauen kann beziehungsweise die
positionsdaten für die rennen das ist cool das ist cool nicht mal wireless controller cringe
er kann programmieren aber keine sound levels angleichen ja da sieht man mal das
sind es hat schon seinen kund warum man informatik oder mediendesign oder wie auch immer das heißt
studieren kann das ding braucht unbedingt eine kamera dann hätte ich also würde das ding so
funktionieren plus kamera das wäre richtig nice da könnte ich beim robot aber im rasen mähen
zugucken das wäre richtig futuristisch den nächstes projekt mache ich erst mal die wetterstation
ich würde mal interessieren wie er das gebaut hat es wird er doch jetzt in zweieinhalb minuten nicht
unterbringen können ok anscheinend doch wie genau wäre eigentlich bluetooth gar nicht mit bluetooth
kannst du nicht gescheit position feststellen mit bluetooth kannst du höchstens empfangsstärken
feststellen und daran ungefähr ableiten wie weit du von deiner basisstation weg bist oder vom aber
das bringt dir nix das finde ich ist eine richtig gute idea ich klicke jetzt und die
glocke und die glocke leute ich habe total leute hier wahnsinn ich habe ein total schlechtes
verhältnis von abonnenten zu glocke bei mir auf youtube und warum weil ich schon lange auf youtube
aktiv war bevor es diese glocke überhaupt gab und den größteil meiner abos gemacht hat bevor es die
glocke gegeben hat und nachträglich hat die glocke keiner mehr eingeschaltet die säcke anzeige ist
raus disabo alle alle dis abonnieren ich wobei ich kann die leute ich kann die leute gar nicht
dis abonnieren ich glaube man kann leute nicht doch bannen kann ich sie die abonniert das auch
wenn man leute bann ich habe es ist schock ist bei mir genau das gleiche ich habe bei keinem
einzigen channel wo ich subscribte habe die glocke aktiviert diese musik dabei die passt so
überhaupt nicht aber guckt mal richtig nice der weicht der evaded sogar dem dem posten der
weicht nicht aus der evaded leute dort den posten auf chat chat frage router router question was
ist eigentlich am sinnvollsten einen mieten bei telekom mit dem vertrag einen billigen kauf und
lieber einen teuren das kommt auf an was du machen willst ansonsten also wenn du einfach nur ins
internet willst und da irgendwie keine großartigen ansprüche dran hast dann behalte den von provider
wenn du keinen bock hast dass dein provider theoretisch zugriff hat auf dein internes
netzwerk was da dran hängt dann hol dir den eigenen weil die provider router haben die provider
theoretisch zumindest firmware update möglichkeiten und so was da drauf allein schon das missfällt
mir und in teuren würde ich mir nur kaufen wenn du auch die features davon brauchst also in der
regel reden wir bei sowas im privaten bereich von der fritz box weil du brauchst ja nicht
wirklich einen router du brauchst ja ein multifunktionsgerät du brauchst was mit
modem eventuell je nachdem was du benutzt du brauchst was mit deck basis station du brauchst was mit
wlan mit switch mit einem switch drinnen mit gäste wählen also du brauchst multifunktionsgerät ja und
im prinzip für den heimbereich ist eigentlich eine fritz box so das teil was man da in der
regel hat und jetzt bleibt eigentlich die frage genau der cp ist aber so dinge jetzt bleibt nur
die frage billige fritz box oder teurer fritz box das würde ich ganz klar davon abhängig machen
ob du die features der teuren fritz box brauchst wenn nicht nimm eine billige fritz box ich meine
teure fritz box oder dass du die features verwendest ist nicht besser als eine billige fritz box
das
beispielsweise wlan technisch unterscheiden die sich glaube ich relativ viel was sie unterstützen
sowohl von den antennen als auch vom wlan standard und allem aber wenn du das wlan
beispielsweise gar nicht über die fritz box benutzen willst weil du vielleicht access points
im haus verteilt hast dann ist das schon mal egal also ich habe auch eine fritz box kann
ich an der stelle sagen ich habe eine fritz box allerdings so gut wie einzeln allein als deckt
station für die telefone ich habe die billigste fritz box die es gibt irgendwie 70 euro oder so die
kleinste die es gibt und das einzige was die macht ist woib woib und deckt sonst nix ach ja
ich habe noch vier fritz smart home thermostat daran angemeldet woib ja doch die macht woib
und deckt die thermostate sind ja auch deckt das riecht boomer technologie ja und das reicht ich
habe keinen grund mir eine teurere fritz box zu kaufen festnetz telefon gibt es in dieser in
diesem sinn gar nicht mehr es gibt noch historisch historisch quasi so sachen wie festnetz telefon
nummern die eigentlich in der heutigen zeit auch extrem unsinnig sind weil das ist alles woib und
dementsprechend kannst du das auch im handy empfangen also ich habe ja also ich habe so
gemacht bei mir daheim ich habe meinen meine telefonnummer dass sie die festnetz telefonnummer
die habe ich umgezogen mal irgendwann zu easy bell warum weil das ein woib anbieter ist nicht
bezahlt da irgendwie 2 euro 99 oder so im monat für den für den woib anschluss warum weil
telefonnummer portieren bei anwenderwechseln immer der größte abfakt überhaupt ist also das
schlimmste beim anbieterwechsel sei es jetzt von wo davon zur telekom oder vielleicht irgendwann
mal auch zu deutsche glasfaser oder was auch immer der größte abfakt ist immer telefonnummer
portieren deswegen dachte ich mir ich nehme die telefonnummer einfach mal aus diesem spiel mit
raus und portiere die ganz woanders hin und ich habe die damals zu easy bell portiert portieren
lassen und hab da jetzt den allerkleinsten tarif nur telefon für irgendwie 299 im monat das
reicht mir dicke und dadurch bin ich unabhängig was anbieterwechsel angeht und das ist halt auch
diesmal jetzt richtig echtes komplettes woib wie es im prinzip bei telekom bei wo davon auch ist
nur dass die immer noch so komische dinge haben wird schließt es doch mal an den router an und
sowas das ist woib das bedeutet ich kann auch ohne probleme eine x beliebige woib app oder
sieb app nehmen für mein smartphone und darüber mit meiner festnetznummer telefonieren oder also
wenn ich angerufen werde auf dem festnetz dann klingelt auch mein handy weil ich dann
ein zipclient drauf habe also ich kann wenn ich angerufen werde auf der festnetztelefonnummer
ohne probleme von unterwegs das annehmen weil es auch auf dem handy rauskommt also festnetz in dem
sinn ergibt eigentlich keinen sinn mehr früher hat es noch ein bisschen mehr sinn ergeben als
du noch richtig echte kupferleitung von der telekom hattest wo auch noch telefon drüber
ging inklusive stromversorgung von mindestens einem telefon und so was da war das noch ein
bisschen was anderes gerade für hausnotrufe und so was aber gibt es ja heute nicht mehr
so sollt alles mehr oder weniger also ich glaube es gibt noch ganz ganz wenige ausnahmen zum
beispiel wenn man einen fahrstuhl hat notrufsysteme im fahrstuhl die müssen glaube ich noch per
richtig echte festnetzkram angeschlossen werden aber mal ganz davon abgesehen spätestens ab der
nächsten wie nennt man das ab dem nächsten knotenpunkt der telekom ist es eh woib also
selbst wenn ihr noch ein oldschool analogen telefonanschluss habt spätestens wenn das
bei der nächsten box von der telekom ankommt ist es woib warum decktelefone daheim sind doch
gar nicht so schlecht meine türkingsprecherlage geht auch über deckt hast du ein vpn zu dir
nach hause nein habe ich nicht ja ich habe eine domain gekauft aber ich benutze kein aber ich
benutze kein vpn ich hatte eine ganze weile open vpn bei mir laufen als ich noch pf sens
am eingang hatte dann auch mit client auf dem iphone und so aber ich habe festgestellt ich
brauche es nicht ich verwende ich verwende nix davon also ich habe keinen anwendungszweck
von unterwegs auf ein heimnetz zuzugreifen notizen und bilder synchronisiere ich wenn
ich daheim im wlan bin brauche ich nicht im brauche ich kein internet vpn gedürz positions
tracking mache ich anderweitig muss ich auch nicht über vpn machen und von unterwegs in
meinen heim automatisierung rein zu gucken hat auch wenig sinn also ich habe festgestellt ich
hatte das lange zeit habe es aber eigentlich nie verwendet deswegen habe ich jetzt kein vpn
mehr aber ich habe eine eigene domain für meine internen kisten habe ich eine ganz billige domain
gekauft für glaub drei euro oder so im jahr oder noch billiger und gut ist kann man das absehen
hier mit zwei faktor identifizieren bevor man sich verbinden ja kannst du machen kann man auch
machen ja dass das die möglichkeit gibt es ich kenne mich damit aber nicht gut aus weil ich
lange kein vpn mehr betrieben habe wie machst du das mit dem positions tracking über mqtt ich
benutze wie heißt da graben und track ios ich habe die app und die schickt regelmäßig meine
position an einen mqtt server und mein home assistant ist subscribt an diesen mqtt server
der ist publik der mqtt server und mein home assistant verbindet sich von intern nach außen hast
du auch den verlauf ja aber halt nur intern bei mir in der smart home lösung also ich kann
mir theoretisch angucken wo ich gestern gewesen bin aber warum ja aber würde funktionieren
kannst du dein pc zu hause weltweit ausstarten per weg online der läuft auch nicht 24-7 mein
desktop pc ist nur an wenn ich davor sitze wozu soll ich den starten
brauchst das für reports bei der kunde dann ist was anders ist ja sinnvolles anwendungsgebiet
und dann kann man ja auch vpn machen was ich halt sagen wollte ich hatte kein sinnvolles
anwendungsgebiet und man muss nicht sein netz von außen aufmachen wenn man es nicht braucht also
der der beste schutzleute ist immer noch wenn was gar nicht erst geht und danach abstand aber wenn
was gar nicht erst offen ist müsst ihr euch auch nicht schützen weil es gibt keine verbindungsmöglichkeit
ja das wird signal gescheit ist bei uns aber schwierig auf 2,4 gigahertz wenn ich hier
wählen ich habe mal ich bin hier mal mit nem android android tablet rumgelaufen hat man gemapt
wir haben glaube ich 87 oder sowas fragt mich nicht da nie ganz so viel ist es nicht aber es war
verdammt viel ich weiß es nicht mehr irgendwie keine ahnung 50 oder so 50 60 ssid habe ich hier
gescannt in der nähe aber ist klar hier wurden viele leute
nee open sense habe ich hinter mir habe ich aktuell kein anwendungszweck mehr für
ja aber das bestimmt auch nur mit verschiedenen sendern
dass da dass du dann irgendwie das gebiet absteckt und der das dann quasi sich errechnet aus
empfangsstärke von unterschiedlichen sendern oder sowas weiß ich nicht ich hab konnte meine
telefonnummer portieren zwar gar kein problem weil ich gar kein vpn brauche warum soll ich
in vpn benutzen wenn ich kein vpn brauche kann man so eine sieb telefonnummer kaufen
bei deine mobilfunk anbieter nutzen also wenn man einen anruf auf dem handy bekommt dass man
den rechner dass man auch am rechner abheben kann ja du brauchst ein zip klein das hat mit
dem handy nichts zu tun du bekommst eine zip oder bekommste telefonnummer von einem anbieter und
du bekommst zugangsdaten für einen sieb kleint und er siebt die sieb kleint oder sieb kleint
durch den kannst du auf die deine fritzbox kann das machen dein handy kann das machen
dein desktop pc kann das machen überall wo du in x-beliebischen weib klein installieren kannst
ja kannst du machen also ich habe ich habe ground wire auf dem iphone ground wire app ios also ich
habe das ding als weib app und da hab ich da ruft mich übrigens erwin schrödinger auch öfters
und da kriege ich dann einen anruf aufs handy wenn mich einer auf dem festnetz anruft und ich
könnte ohne probleme und ich könnte ohne probleme auch in x-beliebigen sieb klein für windows
installieren mich da drüber anrufen lassen oder für oder linux oder mac oder so überhaupt kein
ding das funktioniert das heißt es musst du auch nicht bei deinem mobilfunk anbieter nutzen du
hast ja mobiles internet und darüber läuft das dann das hat mit deinem mobilfunk anbieter wenig
zu tun hauptsache du hast mobiles internet oder wlan oder so beobachtet er würde panik
kriegen wenn er so ein rasenmeer rumläuft im bar im garten was rumläuft an rum fährt das ist
richtig vpn sind in der regel klein zertifikate und dann brauchst du eigentlich auch keine zwei
fakte autentifizierung aber wenn man sich wenn man sich sicherer sicherer fühlt kann man das machen
ich mein password und zertifikat sind ja schon zwei fakte autentifizierung aber wenn man kein
password will gibt bestimmt die möglichkeit bei wire gart auch irgendwie so was wie sms
autentifizierung zu machen oder in autentifizierung server einzubinden der das dann für dich mal
gibt es bestimmt habe ich noch nie ausprobiert ist aber eine gute projektidee
das ist eigentlich vpn mit sms ff oder aus erb oder sowas das muss man ausprobieren ich muss
mein pc nicht von unterwegs starten mein desktop pc ist desktop pc warum sollte ich den von
unterwegs starten aber wie gesagt ich erkenne hier anders jeder unterschiedliche anwendungsgebiete
hat so jetzt müssen aber jetzt müssen wir endlich mal weiter gucken was der was der
rasenmäher hier macht wir brauchen wieder ewig für das video das ist wirklich so diese musik
die das ist das ich weiß nicht wo die herkommt aber die hörst du so oft das muss irgendwie so
eine so eine royale tier royale t3 hinter background music stock stock music design space for this
project am scharf robotic mauer this is because you get classic 500 wie viel kostet das den
classic 500 wie schreibt man wie schreibt man moa moa moa moa moa moa moa moa moa moa
yard force ordentlich ja forz also wenn ich eh schon im garten bin naja gut es zieht einfach
immer dass die leute glückliche menschen auf denen auf diesen werbefotos haben
vpn heidet doch wenigstens das tls clients server was
vpn heidet erst einmal gar nichts vpn ist auf auf also du hast du hast da nicht mehr deine deine
ip vom handy die da die der webserver sieht sondern der sieht dann halt deine externe ip
von daheim wenn du über den vpn gehst was was jetzt in den vpn mit irgendeiner tls verbindung
zum server zu tun hat das verstehe ich nicht weil die tls verbindung machst du immer noch
von deinem endgerät zum server hin hat egal ob über vpn oder nicht
ja gut du kannst wenn du so willst du kannst anonymer surfen dahingehend dass du ja schlechter zu
tracken bist vielleicht ja dass jetzt irgendein anbieter nicht mehr sagen kann ok hier ist er
jetzt mobil unterwegs oder hier hat er jetzt diese ip ist befindet sich irgendwo in frankfurt oder
so das könnte du könntest das mit einem vpn vielleicht das tracking ein bisschen erschweren
aber jetzt nicht wirklich großartig ich meine dann sieht er wie gesagt deine ip von daheim anstatt
deine deine handy ip aber ansonsten ändert vpn an tracking relativ wenig das ist ja auch das was
die vpn anbieter immer erzählen was schwachsinn ist ein vpn schützt dich null davor getrackt zu
werden oder nicht du kannst du kannst wenn du getrackt wirst also wenn wenn irgendein anbieter
der meinung ist er möchte jetzt nachvollziehen was denn so die leute die seine webseite verwenden
machen dann schützt sich in vpn nicht davor du hast dann vielleicht eine andere absender ip oder
sowas aber das tracking läuft auch zum größten teil über irgendwelche fingerprints von einem
browser oder wenn du cookies und sachen aktiviert hast darüber da wirst du auch nicht weniger
getrackt oh ich wurde geradet monka es die raspberry pi cloud hey von dir habe ich das
dein name ist ich habe letztes video von dir geguckt auf youtube wo du dich übelst aufgeregt
hast über unify falls du das bist und das fand ich gut weil ich reg mich auch über unify auf
ich reg mich auch in letzter zeit über unify auf wobei ich sagen muss inhaltlich würde ich sagen
war ich nicht ganz d'accord mit dem inhalt des videos aber den punkt sich aufregen über unify
das konnte ich nachvollziehen ja ja aber noch mal zurück zu dieser vpn geschichte also die
vpn für die anbieter sprechen einem da viel aber das ist alles nur die halbe wahrheit zum
größten teil weil deine absender ip ist dann halt die vom vpn anbieter oder die wenn du
dich unterwegs per vpn daheim einwählst oder so von dir daheim aber das ändert beim tracking
ja nichts wie gesagt das tracking funktioniert ja in den seltenen fällen noch also wenn du
im browser machst über irgendwelche absender ip oder sowas das ist ja old school tracking
getrackt wird über irgendwelche anderen sachen die da ein browser aus auszeichnet ja irgendwelche
was beispielsweise im browser relativ beliebt war um festzustellen ob es in unic user ist ist
schriftarten wobei das mittlerweile nicht mehr so einfach geht der neueste trend was was browser
fingerprinting angeht habe ich gelesen ist canvas genau genau 109 395 genau canvas ist der neueste
trend und wisst ihr dass das muss ich euch jetzt mal erzählen das ist wirklich massive
feifert also das ist wirklich so high IQ da musste erst mal drauf kommen wisst ihr was
sie machen um festzustellen also ich muss das muss das noch mal kurz kurz kurz an ich
aber fingerprinting ist wichtig fürs tracking ich muss aber kurz kurz erklärt also wenn du
als anbieter feststellen möchtest ob beispielsweise ein spezieller user was weiß ich immer der ob
dich immer wieder der gleiche user besucht ist jetzt auch erst mal egal dann musst du den user
ja irgendwie identifizieren können du kannst es über seine absender ip machen das ist aber
nicht so schön am besten wäre du kannst das browser spezifisch tracken das heißt du müsst
es jetzt irgendwie rausbekommen welches welche eigenheiten der browser hat deiner benutzer um
sie möglichst eindeutig identifizieren zu können und wenn ich eindeutig dann vielleicht zumindest
gruppen identifizieren zu können und sei es auch nur um ihnen besser produkte zu empfehlen
so und canvas ist eine richtig coole geschichte ich habe mal eine frage an euch chat was man
genommen ich möchte jetzt als anbieter erkennen welches betriebssystem ihr verwendet oder mit
welchem gerät ihr euch mit welchem gerät ihr meine webseite verwendet so und ihr teilt mir
das nicht mit ihr teilt mir das nicht mit also ihr habt keinen kleinen string oder sonst was im
browser also ihr wollt gar nicht dass ich das mit bekomme was können wir machen font ja font
ist das eine font rendering ist das eine font rendering und wisst ihr was und und wisst ihr
was beliebtes emojis wenn ich ein emoji render und danach gucke wie das emoji aussieht weiß ich auf
welcher plattform ihr unterwegs seid weil ios emojis sehen anders aus als android emojis sind
anders aus als windows emojis sehen anders aus als samsung oder sonst was emojis das heißt die
machen ein ganz easy gesagt die machen ein verstecktes canvas auf ihrer webseite malen
ein emoji da rein was halt der font renderer vom jeweiligen browser auf diesem jeweiligen
betriebssystem macht und danach gucken sie sich das canvas an und schauen welches emoji wurde
denn gemalt wenn es ein ios emoji ist wissen sie aha ist wohl ein ios safari benutzer es gibt ja
unter ios prinzipiell nur safari wenn du den android emoji hast den aha guck mal das ist ein
android emoji das ist eigentlich richtig feifett und es gibt noch mehr möglichkeiten zum beispiel
kannst du sogar relativ gut habe ich letztens was darüber gelesen feststellen was für hardware
ausstattung der pc hat weil du kannst einfach gucken wie schnell kann der bestimmte sachen malen
ja du machst einfach berechnungen die cpu intensiv sind du machst vielleicht kurze berechnungen die
gpu intensiv sind sei es über webgl oder sonst was was malen im hintergrund und daran kannst du
relativ gut feststellen was für eine hardware ausstattung der pc hat und das alles wohl gemerkt
ohne dass der klein browser dir das mitteilt das ist ein richtig richtig big brain ja ich weiß
gar nicht wie wir da drauf gekommen sind aber da schütze ich in vpn ich davor genau davon hatten
wir es ja genau und wenn du das in kombination machst auflösung canvas geschichten render
geschwindigkeit font rendering dann hast du einen ziemlich guten fingerprint also quasi
so kombination aus allem ist relativ einzigartig dann pro user das heißt du kannst leute tracken
aktivierte deaktivierte features genau du kannst du kannst quasi leute tracken obwohl sie nicht
wollen dass du sie tracks und da hilft in vpn absolut gar nichts gegen vpn hilft übrigens
auch nicht dass das ganze sicherer wird weil das einzige was bei einem vpn zusätzlich verschlüsselt
ist ist der weg von dir zum vpn aber der weg vom vpn zum server auf den du willst weil da die
webseite liegt ist wenn es unverschlüsselt ist genauso unverschlüsselt wie vorher also eigentlich
bringt vpn in 95 prozent der fällen nicht das was die vpn anbieter versprechen wofür es was bringt
wofür es was bringt ist wenn man sich zum beispiel sicherheits kopien runterladen möchte über
torrent oder sowas was wir natürlich alle nicht machen oder wenn man zum beispiel über offenes
ja swiss schock wenn man über ein offenes wlan zum beispiel ins internet geht wo jeder
x beliebige dude der da mit im notebook rumsitz mitlesen könnte dann ist das sinnvoll über
vpn zu gehen aber das machen die meisten leute nicht die meisten leute verwenden vpn nicht
dafür die meisten leute verwenden vpn weil ein youtuber in seinem youtube video erzählt hat mit
vpn anbieter xy ist das alles viel mehr privacy und viel sicherer und und und viel viel besser
ja obwohl es das eigentlich gar nicht ist für die meisten anwendungszwecke
so jetzt hätten wir das auch jetzt können wir eigentlich das video mit dem rasen mehr
endlich weiter gucken ich hab jetzt ewig gebraucht aber gut ich weiß nicht wie wir jetzt von rasen
mehr auf vpn und browser gekommen sind aber immerhin man muss ich bin ja meister des seit
seit trackings ja man kann javascript deaktivieren das ist wahr aber mit deaktiviertem javascript
funktioniert halt das internet heutzutage nicht mehr oder das internet ist jetzt natürlich auch
technisch gesehen falsch die webseiten funktionen heute halt nicht mehr ohne javascript
leute kennt noch jemand kennt noch jemand den alten netz capen navigator
aber gerade bei solchen was ist das für eine bildauflösung alter größeres bild ging nicht
oder was gut 644 80 war vielleicht damals angesagt ja das hatte damals sogar schon
ein html editor besser als frontpage war ja kann man sich aber nicht darauf verlassen ja dafür
ist es sinnvoll ja tor ist ein für feilscherring weniger zu gebrauchen natürlich nur für linux
distribution ja oder sicherheits kopieren nein habe ich nicht habe ich mich am anfang
des streams lang darüber ausgelassen will ich jetzt nicht noch mal alles erzählen
du meinst ssl nicht ssh oder gut gucken uns das video jetzt weiter an gibt es
ein unterschütt per ssl und tls das ist eine gute frage ich glaube ich glaube nicht das
eine ist was mich mal überlegen also tl also ssl ist tls so viel so viel ist klar wobei
ich mir nicht sicher bin ob sich ssl nicht vielleicht auf eine spezial variante von tls
bezieht ach so war das genau ja gut ja dann dann passt das dann passt das ssl 3 tls 10
sind wir nicht bei 12 mittlerweile schon du bist im livestream ja du bist hier unten irgendwo
oder 13 sogar schon also könnte man auch tl ja könnte man könnte man sagen wobei korrekter
weise eigentlich nicht das sondern wie heißt dieser zertifikat an zertifikat steine x 509
müsstest du eigentlich sagen wobei das niemand sagt die chinesen haben tls 1.3 eine zeit lang
blockiert die chinesen block block block blockieren ziemlich viel vor allem übrigens auch gerade den
hafen in shanghai habe ich gehört was macht eigentlich der shanghai hafen kann man wieder
bei aliexpress bestellen oder sind die china chinesen immer noch dabei und sagen wir lassen
keine schiffe rein hafen von shanghai staut sich da immer noch stau stau
weiß ich ob das immer noch immer noch so ist gut jetzt gucken wir endlich mal das video weiter kann
ich sein dass ich da wieder drei stunden für brauche um den fünf minuten video über den
mehrroboter zu sehen so wir fangen jetzt hier an der stelle noch mal an dass er uns erklären kann
wie er die hardware von seinem gps getrackten mehrroboter zusammen gewusstet hat
aber wie hat er denn jetzt das ich meine der muss ihn ja irgendwie smart gemacht haben mit
dem raspberry pi oder dem esp oder wie cheaper than buying the components individually electronics
insider replaced by custom ones and the designs of course open source in the open more project
this more is very hacker friendly because all electronics are connected using standard das
das so ein standard attx stecker das finde ich schon mal gut dass sie da nicht irgendwie welche
dass sie nicht so china style graben machen wo danach erst mal kunstharz über das bord gekippt
wird oder sowas using standard mollix connectors but now let's look at the custom hardware the main
processing is done by a respiratory platform it runs the larger part of the open more software
for example navigation and localization all real-time tasks are handled by the small
raspberry pi pico microcontroller which is located below the armatana 2
der raspberry pi ist zum ist zum steuern von von stepper motoren und so glaube ich nicht so geil
aber das warum hat er denn da zwei an genug rechenleistung hat er der pie auf jeden fall
ja artikel gps board the three motors are controlled using three xc motor controllers
those are also an open source project of mine also das machst du wirklich nicht von heute auf
morgen ich habe gedacht das ist ein easy mod der pub da jetzt in raspberry pi 4 mit gps modul rein
und gut ist dass es tatsächlich deutlich komplizierter als ich mir das jetzt
erst mal vorgestellt hat stu vorgestellt habe some connectors for emergency stops and the user
interface as well as a sound module ich meine da ist ja von dem ursprünglichen bord kaum noch was
übrig fits in the original shell and so the buttons can be used as expected if you want to build
da ist nichts mehr vom original drinnen ok das ist natürlich nicht so einfach mal nebenbei
gemacht zeig mal hier projekte github ob ich ihn gedudel 2,6 k das schaue sehr nice
ross soll das real-time operating system sein ross fjr 100 ich glaube niemand hat
dieses projekt ab sich anschaut ist 100 prozent sicher was er macht wie dann auch hat es
davor noch nie gemacht intro video ok das ist da bist du einen monat mit beschäftigt bis das
funktioniert das ist eher was ich glaube das ist eher was wenn man halt bock hat mal länger
fristig was zu basteln weniger als wenn man einen also wenn man jetzt sagt man möchte einen mehr
roboter haben der halt einfach funktionieren soll besser besser heute als morgen dann ist das
projekt wahrscheinlich nicht dass das ist glaube ich eher was wenn man sagt ich möchte hauptsächlich
ein bastelprojekt haben und am ende kommt vielleicht ein funktionierender mehr roboter
raus dann hier das spanungswandel hat er hier und das ist ein das der gps sensor vielleicht
das hier gps oder was meint ihr
oder ist das beschleunigung sensor oder sowas
sound module kann auch was sagen dann ok da hast du was zu tun
da hast du was zu tun bis du das gebaut hast
hoffentlich nicht c++ c++ war ja klar na gut was sonst ja sei es jetzt ob es
irgendwelches arduino kompatibles zeug das ist alles letztendlich c++ zwar abfack hoch 10 aber
kommst du nicht drumherum ja also bis du das gebaut hast hast du echt was zu tun
aber coole idee kennst du dich mit laura waren aus ja wir haben sogar mal laura sachen gebaut
im stream vor jahren weiß ich nicht laura lowlevel zeugs und 1,5 kilometer datenübertragung esp 32
wasser sensor wifi laura ja haben wir haben wir hier gemacht guck da zeug zeug haben wir da gemacht easy
den habe ich aber nicht im einsatz gehabt den sensor warum sind die laura gateways so teuer
weil das oder wie hieß der kram multichannel gateways oder sowas sind du brauchst aber nicht
unbedingt ein gateway du kannst auch irgendeinen esp 32 nehmen mit dem laura modul da musst du
halt selbst basteln das ist richtig dass das richtig laura ist das eigentliche protokoll also
dass das lowlevel was das dann layer layer 1 und 2 übertragung stimmt und wenn du so sachen wie
tt wie hast das ding ttn ttn heißt glaube ich machen willst dann musst du noch ein bisschen mehr
basteln du kannst mich was fragen es ist jetzt aber nicht so als hätte ich damit wahnsinnig viel
gemacht ja also frage ruhig ich habe was ich gemacht habe ist ich habe empfänger gebaut und
also laura ding was ich bei mir daheim stellen kann was daten empfängt und ich habe einen
bodenfeuchtigkeits sensor gebaut mit einem low power esp 32 dran der zum kürzten teil im
deep sleep ist und dreimal am tag aufwacht und den feuchtigkeit vom vom boh also widerstand vom
boden wo man die bodenfeuchtigkeit draus ableiten kann heim sendet das habe ich gebaut das hat auch
funktioniert aber ich habe es am endeffekt nie verwendet ja wissen wir wofür das gedacht war
ich glaube ich habe das schon öfters erzählt aber sind jetzt ein paar neue leute weil das war
ursprünglich dafür gedacht dass ich im sommer weiß wann ich auf den friedhof fahren muss zum
grab von oma und opa und gießen muss der friedhof ist nicht so weit weg und das hat für die
entfernung mit laura übertragung geklappt da wollte ich eigentlich eine wasserdichte box nehmen und
die neben dran legen und den bodenfeuchtigkeits sensor in das in das grab buddeln und dann konnte
mir das bescheid sagen wann ich hin muss gießen und wann ich habe ich aber nie gemacht bisher
also ich habe es ich habe es dann nie wirklich verwendet also war eher so eine so eine idee das
zu machen habe ich aber nie gemacht ja du kannst auch ja das geht auch leider kann ich meinen
briefkasten nicht gescheit automatisieren weil der zu schepp ist max automatisiert den friedhof
naja buddeln halt den den den bodenfeuchtigkeits sensor da reinstecken dass es nicht direkt siehst
von außen weil ansonsten wir haben leute auf dem friedhof schon sachen geklaut das hat man
jemand unsere gießkanne geklaut auf dem friedhof es hat mir jemanden plumen geklaut auf dem friedhof
und einmal ist jemand mit einem reifen über das grab drüber gefahren da hat irgendein bugger
buddler auf dem friedhof nicht aufgepasst oder so also wer denkt da passiert nix ja die leute
klauen sachen auf dem friedhof wer denkt da passiert nix da würde ich mich nicht darauf
verlassen als halt frankfurt und umgebung aber die haben die gießkanne also die gießkanne war weg
und es hat mal einer blumen geklaut
ja aber du musst am briefkasten irgendwo den schalter anbringen und bei mir ist die klappe zu
wackelig habe ich auch schon überlegt so was gucken wir denn jetzt noch leute ich habe zwar
hunger aber eine sache gucken wir jetzt noch felby danke für den sub 12 monate jetzt war es zum
ersten mal den kichs mit goldene halskette erlangt massif mehr gibt es nicht was quasi
das höchste achievement anlockt er entfernungssensor das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt ob ich da
nicht so was rein machen soll dass ich erkenne wenn post also wenn post drinne ist erkennt man
das ja da bin ich mir nicht so sicher wie gut das in in der box funktioniert zumal das problem ist
an einem entfernungssensor den musst du dauerhaft mit strom versorgen dass er funktioniert im
vergleich zu einem schalter den schalter kann ein esp oder sowas triggern dass es
auslöst in ihr sensor muss dauerhaft mit strom versorgt werden was ihn nicht batterie
batterie tauglich macht oder aber du wachst ab und zu aufmiss die entfernung und sagst dann
bescheid dann ist es mit ziemlicher verzögerung und wenn du zu oft aufwachst verbrauchst auch
zu viel batterie schwierig schwierig es kann nicht so einfach sowas zu bauen wenn man keinen brief
kasten hat der so 0815 ist mit einer schweren klappe ich kriege keine sms von der post wenn
ich was bekomme du brauchst für laura nicht unbedingt ein gateway in dem sinn wenn du wenn
du rein wenn du es reicht wenn du ein wenn du dir ein laura modul kaufst mit einer antenne dran und
dann in den controller und die können miteinander reden also du wenn du zwei controller hast mit
zwei laura modul die können miteinander reden du brauchst kein gateway oder so das ist dann
halb p2p ja wenn du den gateway hast um tnn zu machen dann ist es was anderes da kannst du
nämlich dein laura gerät vielleicht auch außerhalb der reichweite deines eigenen empfängers
betreiben und andere gateways bekommen das dann und schicken zu dir was du hast letztens was für
den für den zeit mal eine erweiterung für mein ikea luftsensor ne das was anderes das ist was
anderes hat mit dem ikea den nix zu tun das ist ihre eigene entwicklung oder das ist dann ah nee
der funktioniert übrigens wunderbar mein ikea luftsensor da steht jetzt hier oben auf dem
schrank und ist aktuell noch grün wollen mal kurz reingucken was der sagt wenn leute ich post
euch das mal kurz ein staub hier so sieht es bei mir gerade im office aus so sieht es bei
mir im office aus da guckt also wir haben 24,3 grad 41 prozent luftfeuchtigkeit 17 microgramm
pro kubikmeter feinstaub und kein gas 180 gas ist gut 180 ist kein gas hoher wert hoher wert gut
niedriger wert schlecht gibt es eine seite außer das streamer schief gibt es nicht wir haben uns
letzte woche das video von ihm dazu angeguckt ja was sage ich dazu so schnell kann es gehen im
endeffekt es ist eigentlich immer die abwägung zwischen bequemlichkeit und sicherheit und ich
glaube keiner kommt lange das kann im prinzip jedem von uns passieren warum wird man von msi
geplogged jetzt müsste ich auch gern das kann im prinzip jedem von uns passieren dass man sich
unglücklicher gerade wenn man winnows verwendet dass man sich unglücklicherweise mal irgendeinen keylogger
oder noch schlimmer irgendwas was sich rootkit mäßig einlistet und gar rechner fernsteuern
kann einfängt und dann ist vorbei weil niemand kommt lange mit einem browser klar der beim
löschen quasi alles beim schließen alles löscht und wegschmeißt man sich jedes mal
neu einloggen muss das hält das macht keiner lange letztendlich ist es die üblich dass die
alte geschichte zwischen sicherheit und bequemlichkeit und das ist eine sache das
kann potenziell jedem von uns passieren man kann natürlich seine sein angriffsoberfläche
oder wie man das denn mal reduzieren ja wenn man zum beispiel eine ledungs vm verwendet wenn man
auf irgendwelche shady seiten gehen möchte oder so das kann man schon mal im prinzip kann
das theoretisch jeden von uns passieren ja gut zwei monitore zweimal pc geschlossene
tür das wird halt warm michael 50 milliarden moin auch wieder am start ja das wüsste ich
auch gern warum es ihm nicht geploggt hat ich weiß es nicht
als beide weh ja bringt ihr aber halt nix wenn du irgendwas hast was ein rechner
fernsteuern kann oder deine sessions abgreift oder im zweifelsfall ein key pass aus dem ram
auslesen kann wenn du das falsche eingefangen hast hast du halt gelitten doch ich habe eine
klimaanlage kann ich nicht ich habe einmal drüben den eiser monitor den habe ich schon
zehn jahre oder länger und auf dem hauptrechner hier habe ich ein bank monitor mit 240 herz
kann ich aber beide nicht großartig für homeoffice empfehlen also jetzt explizit
für homeoffice kann man natürlich auch für homeoffice verwenden aber eigentlich zu teuer
dafür du kannst hier das x beliebige linux verwenden nehmen wenn du wenn du dich nicht
gut damit auskennst nimm linux mint oder ubuntu aber linux mint ist ein bisschen schönere
variante denke ich für für die leute dies einfach nur benutzen linux mint vm truff gibbi
nimm lieber xf ce weil das ein bisschen schneller in der vm läuft weil gnome und kde mögen
ganz gerne 3d beziehungsweise 2d beschleunigung was in der vm nicht richtig funktioniert oder
machst wie ich nehme i3 aber da kommt man als einsteiger eher schlecht mit klar wenn
man windows gewohnt ist glaube ich und fertig linux mint drauf gutes das ist zwar nicht
leichtgewichtig aber leichtgewichtig genug ram hat man heute ram ist doch das einzig
günstige heute ich meine ich muss mit meinen 32 geht auch irgendwo hin ram ist das einzig
günstige heutzutage oder das günstigste von dem wenn man sich heute rechner kaufen will
grafikkarten sind teuer als fack cpu sind teuer als fack mainboards sind teuer als fack
gehäuse alles aber ram geht ram geht ram ist das einzige was halbwegs geht es ist nicht
billig es war schon billiger aber es geht noch halbwegs der preis gempte gibt es nicht mehr
da war mir das pflegen der der crawler zu aufwendig ja aber das macht keiner wirklich
das ist halt das ist was du sagst ist im prinzip sicherheit versus bequemlichkeit das da drehst
dir durch bei du kannst auch einfach alles in der linux vm machen da hast du auch schlechtere
chancen als bessere chancen dir nichts einzufangen da kannst du halt einige sachen vielleicht
nicht darauf machen die du machen willst es halt wie wäre es mit dem wii pinox das wii
pinox ist in ubuntu mit einem custom skin du meinst das hier gell sekunde du meinst
execute vm du meinst das hier heute macht euch auch was gefasst weeps in so das sind
jetzt die 15 sekunden für alle weeps danach mache ich die vm wieder aus ok fertig genug
alles klar so können wir uns youtube technisch noch irgendwas angucken my crazy new storage
server 23 minuten ist mir jetzt aber echt ein bisschen lang warum diese am menschliche
skin ne creative smart home ideas 3d printed ok das können wir uns angucken das sind nur
sieben minuten 57 das ist gut zeit mal her a 3d printer can unlock endless new possibilities
für your smart home i fed akara sensor das ist der standard akara tür tür fenster kontakt
sensor aber warum hochkant 5 hat heim keine ahnung und was surprise me is that 3d printing
is actually pretty easy now i've been printing some things for my smart home ja ich hab sogar
früher schon diese die seite verfolgt bevor den youtube channel hatten in love not only
ist das wurde so auf youtube auch schon mal zensuriert auf videos von mir schon geplockt
wurde ja erst letztens ich habe letztens ein video hochgeladen geladen da habe ich zu
oft das wort x hamster gesagt ich habe so oft das wort x hamster gesagt und ich musste
das video dann fünf mal neu hochladen bis es funktioniert hat hier das da und mittlerweile
ist das video allerdings nur ohne werbung wieder wieder schaubar ich habe ich habe leider zu
oft x hamster gesagt und ich hatte sogar x hamster im titel das war nicht das das geht
nicht das ist gleich block
ok jetzt gucken wir zusammen an
wo ist die wo ist die standard
die standard i3 eule die sehe ich hier nicht wo ist die eule die jeder schon mal ausgedruckt
hat wisst ihr was ich meine diese die das standard model was bei jedem i3 drucker dabei
ist diese eule
i've made some toys for my kids it's been a lot of fun but they have this website called
thingiverse
das benchy schiff genau
like this cord organizer holder thing download the file print it and it cost me around 10
cents to make
ich überlege gerade wozu bräuchte man sowas
ich habe zwar hier jede menge usb kabel liegen aber die meisten stecken in geräten drinne
ich wüsste jetzt gerade nicht was ich damit machen sollte
doch ich weiß wofür ich das brauche
das ist gar nicht schlecht handy richtig das genau das ist mir auch gerade aufgefallen
handy auflade stecker
das ist gar nicht schlecht ich glaube sowas drücke ich mir nachher aus
oh cringe joke alter ultra cringeyer witz wieder der typ ist teilweise echt paints champ
so ein teil habe ich auch leider leider war ich doof und habe mir ein elektronisches gekauft
die batterie von den dingern ist so schnell leer das ist useless as fuck
ich mein man kann es trotzdem ablesen auch wenn es nicht elektro also man kann es trotzdem
hier ablesen aber ich hätte mir was anderes kaufen sollen
ich habe ich habe den mic ich habe den mic clip
mit so einer klammer dran das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut
da wäre ich nie auf die idee gekommen jeder ein zu zu drucken mit mit einem 3d drucker
aber aktuell brauche ich sie nicht weil ich seit zeit auf habe
doch doch du kannst die batterie wechseln aber ich habe keinen bock drauf immer wenn
ich es brauche dann die batterie zu wechseln
das ist eine richtig gute idee es gibt normalerweise solagesensoren für garagentor
und sowas aber das finde ich ist eine wirklich gute idee da kann man nämlich eine 0815 fenster
kontakt oder türkontakt sensor verwenden für das garagentor das finde ich ist wirklich
eine gute idee
das muss dann aber außen an das tor ne warum kannst du innen ans tor pappen innen ans tor
und wenn das tor hoch geht dann dann schwingt das runter
es sogar sinnvoll innen ans tor zu machen dann wobei es geht in beide richtungen ja
ich würde das hier mit der unterseite dran hängen das geht kannst du innen ins tor machen
dass wenn du das innen dran machst fällt das teil auf das tor
moment moment also wenn ich wenn ich in garagentor wenn ich in garagentor habe
das garagentor das geht dann meistens irgendwie so auf
mal so also die garage die garage ist hier so
hier ist der ausgang von der garage und dann mache ich das hier innen dran wo ist denn das
problem wenn das tor zu also der sensor der sensor würde da jetzt der sensor würde da
jetzt quasi so irgendwie dran hängen so und dann hier quasi runter runter hängen
und wenn ich das tor zu mache dann ist das tor so dann ist das wenn ich das zu mache
dann ist das tor so und alter paint man so schlecht
ne das ist innen so und wenn ich das wenn ich das zu mache dann ist der ich kriege anfälle
paint hör mal auf so wenn ich das zu mache dann dann ist der sensor
ich finde die idee aber gut ich verstehe die zeichnung nicht wie kann man die zeichnung
nicht verstehen mit meinen krassen paint skills
verstehe das verstehe ich nicht cringe wer die zeichnung nicht versteht
das ist aber ein stolze preis für ein 3d gedrucktes kleines teil hier sieben oder das
geht fünf aber gut ich meine es muss sich irgendwie lohnen letztendlich ja und es lohnt
sich nicht es knapp über selbst kosten preisleuten zu verkaufen ist schon klar
also wenn du keine 3d printer kaufen willst gibt es etwas was du bekommen kannst
die wirklich unvergesslich sind aber nötig sind die nächste stelle ist ein motion sensor
holder und wenn du das siehst du wirst du sagen read das ist nur eine box und du bist
richtig es ist eine box aber es ist die exakten dimensionen für diese motion aber warum kann
ich den motion sensor nicht einfach so hinstellen oder warum kann ich wenn ich ihn an die wand
machen will nicht einfach den motion sensor an die wand kleben anstatt die box an die
sensor habe ich nicht kapiert aber der kann das doch auch so ranpappen oder verstehe ich
das jetzt nicht oder schraubt er diese der schraub diese box da dran und steckt es dann
da rein jetzt habe ich glaube ich war weil mir ein bisschen heißt kleber wird das auch
mit dem sensor so funktionieren der ihr stimmt dazu kann es einfach rausnehmen
okay ist doch gar nicht so schlecht ja verstehe ich okay ja ja okay leuchtet mir ein
beidem das ist der kerl da daheim irgendwie sieben verschiedene fernsehs hat und 85 verschiedene
apps auf seinem smartphone brauche um sein smartphone bedienen zu können was genau ist
der vorteil davon anstatt dass er seinen echo einfach auf den schreibtisch stellt das habe
ich diesmal nicht kapiert es sieht fancy aus aber das ist eh nicht das richtige für mich
bei mir kommt weder siri noch alexa noch google home oder sonst was aus platz auf dem tisch
also wenn das nicht genug platz auf dem tisch ist da will er mein tisch nicht sehen
diese 3d gedruckten sachen sind erstaunlich widerstandsfähig also gerade wenn man auch
die möglichkeit hat hier außen dann sowas mit infill zu drucken oder so das ist wirklich
echt stabil also wenn du also ich würde mal behaupten wenn ich keine ahnung ich würde
wirklich mit ordentlich infill zwei 2 sachen drucken die ich bei mir an die treppe dran
klipsen könnte von unten da könnte ich mich da ohne probleme dran hängen das wird es
aushalten ja für outdoor ist es nicht unbedingt gut das stimmt wobei ich selbst da sagen würde
zum größten teil sollte das sollte das sollte das eigentlich eine weile halten aber was
ich meine es ist es ist also es hält viel aus belastungstechnisch das ist hätte ich
am anfang nicht gedacht es kann natürlich auch manchmal pains jam werden wenn man was
ausgedruckt hat mit zu viel support und infill zeug und man braucht es nicht und muss es
dann rauskratzen aber ansonsten ist das wirklich viel stabiler als ich das ursprünglich gedacht
hätte
ok
Braucht Kein, Mensch
Das ist Übrigens was was ich mir auch schon öfters überlegt habe
Wenn man nur ein Paar leds braucht man Kann Ja die led strips Auseinanderschneiden Die Funktionieren wunderbar also Du Kannst Aus einem led strip
Der in meterlang ist Kannste Ohne probleme
Paar Zentimeter Lange Häppchen Machen also Die Funktionieren Komplett unabhängig voneinander die leds
Da Muss man sich nicht extra was Kaufen
Naja Ich Weiß nicht
Ich kann es für Notifikationen benutzen um die unterschiedlichen Farben zu verändern also wenn jemand zu der Tür kommt, kann ich es flaschen
Blut Das ist eine gute Idee Aber Ganz Ehrlich Entweder sitze ich hier vorm pc oder ich habe mein handy Irgendwie Dabei und und sonst wie was
Notifikationen
Kriege ich auch Kriege ich auch so also ich kriege die meisten Notifikationen aufs handy
Also Keine Ahnung Wenn Es hof Tor auf geht zum Beispiel und sowas
Aber das ist Dein nice to have also das ist Eigentlich um meine zwecke
Phone battery ist getting low
Jello Packages Left at the door can Flash orange
Or if I need to start wrapping up work and get ready for dinner then it can change the red so there's a lot
Du die Notifikation über Die Home Assistant App
Die Haben auch Apple Apple push notifications gehen damit auch
Of that the light is not too bright or distracting, but it still looks incredible on the desk
So if you're thinking about getting a 3d printer
I recently bought this ender 3s one and I've loved it because it's giving me zero issues
Das ist doch so der ein das ist doch aktuell die der ender drucker das ist doch so dieser einsteiger 3d drucker der überall empfohlen wird
Im Einer ist schon ein, bisschen älter ich weiß ich bin da kann ich mal im aktuellsten stand aber diese ender drucker sind auch so die einsteiger tips schlechthin
Nutzt du Android oder IOS für dein smart home weder noch mein smart home läuft auf
In der linux kiste in der vm also läuft auf linux basis
Endgeräte es ist eine mischung ich habe sowohl Android endgeräte als auch IOS endgeräte also mobile sachen und
schiel tv und sowas alles alles mögliche dabei
weder noch also ich habe nichts
Laufen auf IOS oder auf Android was jetzt die heimautomatisierung selber machen würde ich habe nur endgeräte
Automatisches bed leveling hätte ich auch gerne bei meinem 3d drucker beziehungsweise dass er sich das misst und einstellt
Und was ein akt das war unten an diesen rädchen das alles richtig einzustellen das war eklig
rdramatic
긴
Ich bin
Fantastic
said
Plan
tadi
Wie oft man schon das Bett levelt, ich hab das, ne, ich hab's einmal scheiße
gelevelt, aber richtig mega kacke gelevelt, da sind die Sachen nicht
hängen geblieben, das war aber als ich den neu hatte, da hatte ich keine Ahnung
von und dann habe ich irgendwann mich mal zwei, drei Stunden hingesetzt, das
ordentlich gelevelt mit Testdrucken und seitdem, seitdem ist es eigentlich
gelevelt, ja. Auf der anderen Seite muss man aber sagen, ich könnte mir schon
vorstellen, dass das sich mit der Zeit ein bisschen verzieht oder, oder keine
Ahnung, weiß ich gar nicht, dass es mit der Zeit vielleicht ein bisschen
elastischer wird oder so und deswegen finde ich ja die, dieses automatische,
was beispielsweise die, diese Prusa Printer haben, also diese wurde 1000 Euro
plus pro Drucker bezahlt, finde ich halt sehr nice, dass die dann automatisch
auch noch am Anfang gucken und so einen, so ein Profil erstellen für Unebenheiten
und sowas, das ist richtig, richtig nice, aber da musste die halt erstmal 1000
Euro 3D Drucker kaufen. Schon mal von Resin 3D Printer gehört, ja, das ist cool
für Leute, die keine Ahnung, Warhammer Figuren drucken wollen oder sowas.
Ein Kollege von mir auf der Arbeit, der steht richtig auf, auf so Warhammer
Sachen zum selbst bemalen und sowas, für den ist ein Resin, Resin, Resin, wie
das aus, Kunstharz heißt das glaube ich auf Deutsch, 3D Drucker natürlich POC.
Wie das war es schon?
War jetzt aber nicht so viel dabei, aber trotzdem nice, nice Wit.
So, was empfiehlt uns YouTube denn noch?
Erkenntnisse aus meinem smarten Garten.
Kann nicht alles klappen, daraus lernt man ja auch was.
Okay, können wir uns noch irgendwas angucken? Was haben wir noch zu bieten?
Storage. Building a card shooting Lego Tank. 19 Minuten, nein. Das Nein, das
Direct Video habe ich noch nicht geguckt, das ist aber auch zu lang.
Leute, ich bin jetzt drei Stunden an, ich gehe jetzt was essen. Ich gehe jetzt
was essen und vielleicht, vielleicht noch nicht sicher machen wir heute Abend den
Label-Champ weiter oder, oder irgendwas anderes. Kann man auch bei einem, Moment
was? Kann man auch bei einem günstigen Drucker auch nachlesen? Ja, ich wollte
gar nicht so viel an dem 3D Drucker rumbasteln. Ich verwende meinen 3D Drucker
eh nicht so oft. Ich habe mir das viel, viel nützlicher vorgestellt, also ich
dachte ja, als ich mir den 3D Drucker geguckt habe, habe ich mir das
nützlicher vorgestellt, also ich dachte ja, als ich mir den 3D Drucker gekauft habe,
habe ich mir das nach dem Motto, ich drücke da wöchentlich mehrere Sachen aus.
Letztendlich ist es so, dass ich vielleicht alle zwei Wochen mal was
kleines drucke.
Peepofett. Danke Leute, ja. Wir könnten, wir gehen jetzt einfach alle, chat, wir
gehen jetzt alle was futtern zusammen. Also jeder für sich, aber geistig mit dem
Chat. Gehen wir jetzt alle was essen. Ich glaube, ich hole mir jetzt ein paar
Nudeln. Ich habe noch Nudeln übrig. Die guten italienischen teuren Nudeln von
diesem italienischen Internetshop, den ich euch schon mal gezeigt habe.
Mamma mia.
Mal schnell, ob ich irgendjemand hosten kann. Nämlich Follower und der nicht schon
so viele Viewer hat, der das, der das bräuchte.
TC Bounty spielt wieder Battlefield 3, Kegwaid. Der geht immer, das finde ich
nice, dass das noch gespielt wird. Den haben wir letztens erst gehostet. JVPeak ist
online, haben wir aber auch letztens erst gehostet.
Gut Leute, ich bin jetzt wieder auf dem Weg, ich bin jetzt wieder auf dem Weg,
ich bin jetzt wieder auf dem Weg, ich bin jetzt wieder auf dem Weg, ich bin jetzt
wieder auf dem Weg. Gut Leute, egal, ich gehe jetzt auf. Wir sehen uns beim
uns beim nächsten Mal, bis denn, see you!